energy committee as his customary I
would ask you all to rise and join
representative McGee as she leads us in
United States of America to the rep for
it stands one
all I appreciate everybody coming out
today on what is a bit of a wintry day
here in New Hampshire we have a fully a
full of activity here today we
have four public hearings scheduled for
today three this morning and one this
afternoon we also have a full committee
work schedu session scheduled for this
afternoon and an exec session scheduled
for this afternoon the exact session
that's scheduled at 3 pm is for House
Bill
dfn relative to energy procurement
agreements for for default
service with the agreement of the
ranking member we have also decided to
exec House Bill
1627 relative to
rodifer railroads transportation and
Telecommunications we will be hearing
that bill later this morning so that's
the schedule for our activity today and
so before we start our first public
hearing I would ask if there are any
matters that members of the committee
begin seeing none I guess we can begin
so I'm going to open a public hearing on
House Bill
1036 relative to assessment of cost
effectiveness of the system's benefits
charge and I'm going to ask the prime
sponsor of this legislation to introduce
Harrington representative Arington the
yours and I'd remind you representative
that we need a pink card from you not
right this minute
off well thank you Mr chairman good
morning
everybody hope no one died from the
death storm because I mean after all
according to channel 9 if we get 2 Ines
of snow we should just hide in that
basement um anyways this bill what it
does is basically allows more
flexibility to the Pu we set this uh uh
the way it was written before was
basically said in the past saying that
they had to con continue with the method
for reviewing cost Effectiveness on the
um assistant benefit charg and we I
don't see the need to to keep the the Pu
uh in this locked into the past way of
doing things uh that was done a few
years ago and the plan will last for a
few more years this simply says allow
more flexibility so that they can look
longer term at this and see if there's
maybe a better way of doing it the uh
you know the legislature of course takes
a little bit longer to get things done
so if we wanted to change this it could
take upwards of a year by the time you
get through this house and the Senate
and the governor and everything when the
Pu has a lot more flexibility if there
was some changes they could have
hearings and move the process up and the
Pu and the department of energy will
both speak on this later so I'm going to
defer most of it to them but I think
it's just a good it's a good turn uh
tool to give them more flexibility I
mean that's what we pay them to be there
for so they can evaluate these issues
rather than lock them into a methodology
that's going to be four or five years
old by the time they revisit this again
so again I'd say I'd defer most of the
questions to them unless someone has
something specific for me
thank you representative Harrington for
introducing this bill I have one quick
question the way the bill is constructed
on lines two and
three it strikes four words and those
four words would mean that the entire
paragraph would only apply to the filing
that was made on March 1st 2022 is that
correct yes that is correct okay thank
you further questions from the
committee representative Kaplan has
one thank you Mr chair and thank you rep
representative Harrington for taking my
question um the analysis says that it
modifies the this bill modifies the
assessment but I don't know who wrote
that it seems to eliminate the
assessment uh completely
so my question is you know you you say
it gives the Pu greater flexibility but
what problem are you trying to solve
what is the problem with this
methodology and what repl I mean how can
we just strike you know a methodology of
assessing the cost Effectiveness without
having something in place isn't it a
good idea to assess the cost
Effectiveness yeah the intent is not to
get rid of the cost Effectiveness it's
just to give them more flexibility to do
that so we have right now it says
forever and ever you should use this
methodology that was developed I think
in 2020 or something like that I don't
have the exact date but again the other
speak because we'll have that
information and lock Us in Forever is
that's the way to do it this would
simply say we allow them F they still
have to do it but they allow the
flexibility with changing situations to
maybe use different metrics or whatever
it it certainly doesn't eliminate it
because we want to they've been doing
that for well at least the 20 years I've
been involved in this they've been
presenting that doing it and presenting
it to the legislature and want that to
continue but it just allows them to say
two years from now maybe there's a
different methodology we should be using
to determine the effectiveness that's
all yeah follow up follow up my question
is what is wrong can you I mean is there
what problem is this trying to solve
with the old methodology like well it's
trying to solve the problem of not being
allowing any flexibility and changes
with time so if three years from now the
Pu says we can improve the way we do
this to get more accurate results they
locked into a methodology that was set
in I whatever it was 2020 or something
like that and this would allow them to
change that and say okay here's a better
way of doing this maybe I don't know
maybe Nebraska did some studies and
found out there's a better way to to to
analyze this and get more accurate
results and we'd want to follow that it
just gives them flexibility that's
all further questions from the committee
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Harrington for taking my
question um so from the description that
you've given your your answer is that
changing the language removing on lines
two and three and future plan offerings
would mean in statute that uh our
practice of using the granite state test
is the primary test and the Total
Resource cost test as a secondary test
would be eliminated from the
requirements in terms of the
statute it would be eliminated from a
requirement but not eliminated as a tool
it would allow the Pu the flexibility to
say we've looked around there is no
better way to do this we're going to
continue to do it the same way or it
would say
we want to change this a little bit
because we found some other metrics that
give more accurate results of this so it
doesn't eliminate anything it just
allows flexibility followup followup so
along those lines I guess I will be able
to ask other speakers that are coming up
afterwards though but weren't these two
tests sort of hard fought for hard one
in terms of determining which way we
should be assessing costs in other words
there's already been a whole process in
order to get us to the point where we're
using these as tools correct at the time
that is correct but it's it's dated now
and it'll be much more dated when it's
Revisited in a couple of years so I'm
just saying it may be the evaluation
comes out to keep it exactly the same
the whole point of this is to give the
Pu uh more flexibility to look at things
that might have changed over time or
better methods that were developed by
whoever Vice chair Thomas has a question
uh thank you Mr thank you for taking my
question just to reiterate what you said
earlier and to paraphrase what what
you're were saying uh you're basically
saying that it kind of takes away the
old feeling of of people saying we've
always done this way so why change it it
makes that statement say maybe there is
a better way some on time I have to
agree with that yes
okay additional questions representative
Bernardi has a
question thank you Mr chair uh were you
the primary author of this or were you
asked to do this by the people I was
asked by do8 thank
you further questions from the
committee seeing none I want to thank
you representative Harrington for
introducing this legislation and next
I'll call on Alex spidel from the New
Hampshire Public Utilities Commission to
testify on this legis proposed
legislation welcome to stn Good Morning
Good Morning uh thank you chairman V and
members of the committee for having me
speak on behalf of the New Hampshire
Public Utilities Commission on these
issues today I am Alex spidel a senior
advisor and attorney at the
commission uh in the interest of
enabling others to have time to get
their points across and as I have other
testimonial responsibilities before the
Senate this morning I will be brief the
commission is broadly supportive of the
legislature continuing to set the
overall System benefit charge budget as
it removes a locust of controversy
regarding overall spending that is best
handled by the ultimate budgeting
Authority the general court through its
enactments that said the commission
would encourage this committee and the
legislature at large to consider
adopting an approach that would return
to what prevailed before
2021 on the issue of the pu's assessment
of cost Effectiveness for utility Energy
Efficiency in line with the traditional
regulatory model that applied to this
field from the turn of this century this
approach would be applied to the next
trianal plan cycle beginning in
2027 in our view it is important for the
commission to make sure that the people
of New Hampshire who are paying for
these programs through the system
benefits charge are actually benefiting
from these
programs the amount of money being spent
by the utilities with rap pair funds in
a tri-annual plan cycle is large
approximately a quar billion
dollars the commission indicated in its
recent trianal plan order that it had
some concerns in the areas of being able
to assess cost Effectiveness
properly the commission believes that
being able to apply proven economic
Concepts such as discount rates that
accurately reflect the time value of
money and cost benefit ratios informed
by empirical economic studies and
reviewed by the commission are important
for the goal of getting these programs
right and doing what's best for New
Hampshire making sure that the regulated
utility monopolies are spending the rate
payers money wisely is what we at the
puc do and have done through the system
benefit charge dockets in the past 20
years as of now for the most recent Tri
annual plan 97% of the spending is not
subject to the commission's
scrutiny from that angle the commission
also supports the remarks made by the
department of energy Representatives
commissioner Elms and Dr AR today many
consideration thank you questions for Mr
spidel representative Bernardi has a
question thank you Mr chair so in
summary you concur or not concur with
this Bill yes representative Bernardi I
was cautious because I hadn't read the
the language of the bill before I had
arrived I had seen an earlier version of
it online then it went away over the
long weekend so when I read it I said
yes this would effectuate essentially
giving the commission its flexibility to
consider future plans using its
traditional economic analysis approach
thank you thank you representative McGee
has a question thank you Mr chair um my
question is around the decisions that we
made to try and stabilize funding under
HB 549 in 2022 so um there was an effort
by this committee to try and determine a
way to put something in statute that
would
satisfy uh the stability of the New
Hampshire saves program and how it's
funded and also to give Clarity around
if there are going to be increases what
they would be so there would be you know
a modest um but uh sort of market-based
increases as part of the statute so what
does that do to to that decision and
that effort if we sort of undo it with
this um I think that you're referring to
the overall budget being set by the
general court and as I indicated my
remarks the commission supports that
because ultimately the system benefits
charge is akin to the legislature's
budget setting Authority and so that is
the general court making decision this
is the overall spending level and so we
support that remaining the way as it is
and so what I see in Mr Harrington's
bill is that it is not uh implicated
what is implicated is the possibility of
examining questions like discount rates
and I'll explain why that's significant
I representative Harrington he referred
at an earlier Point uh this morning to
the fact that some of the data is dated
uh that was fed into these economic
tests that are specified in the language
of this older 2122 bill um the discount
rates that applied they were derived
from a Time roughly 2016 when we had a
zero interest rate policy inflation was
practically zero GDP growth was
practically zero it was a stagnant
period and so the cost of money was
hardly anything it was very small but
now we've been moving through a higher
inflation period so when you feed in
those data points into the models for
assessing cost Effectiveness it comes
out with uh results that are not really
accurate so the idea is that going
forward we would ask experts from the
utilities from the Department of energy
from uh the office of the consumer
Advocate other parties that are
interested in participating in trianal
plan dockets here we are in
2026 what is the good discount rate for
2027 and we'll see where the economics
comes out we may come back to a a low
inflation low growth economy again in
the future but we might not we may have
a high inflation economy that would feed
into a different outcome for assessing
these discount rates does that help your
answer your
question follow up thank you Mr chair
and so um the follow on question would
be the discount rates and other aspects
of the trianal plan when they they still
go in front of the Pu so all those
members to the docket would still have
input right yes so I guess before I
finish because this is my last question
um I guess what I'm trying to get at is
I I still don't see the need for this
change in language for us to effectuate
a way of modifying plans when they're
submitted to the Pu I don't see how
they're prohibited from already asking
those questions and determining those
things so if I may uh Madame
representative I can give you the order
citation uh for everyone to mark down
it's order number 26908 and it's from
26908 and it's from uh November the 30th
2023 and docket de
23068 and there's a lot built into there
so the commission had to assess the
meaning of what the general court had
said in the enactments that came about
and one of the implications if you read
the law carefully is that all of the
metrics and this was Amplified actually
by the parties that were participating
in the docket for this trienal plan
everything was frozen in place not
really even in the way of uh 2020 but
rather 2016 outputs
considerations uh conditions were being
baked in to the 2024 trianal plan so
unfortunately unless something like uh
representative herings bill goes through
in
2027 the commission is going to be stuck
with having to apply discount rates and
other subparts that were baked in 11
years before that in a total different
world representative Ms has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question there there are a
number of different
um I guess measurement criteria cost
studies uh tests that are referenced in
this um in this statute is there a
particular one that is of most
concern I mean I I see the you know the
avoided energy supply cost study the
granted state test the Total Resource
cost test is there any one of those
that's a particular concern I would
answer that in general they all have
good aspects but the problem is the
dated assumptions surrounding discount
rates really are the real issue so they
have um phrases that make sense Within
These examples such as you must have a
cost benefit ratio of at least one that
sounds good but if you're feeding in a
discount rate that was in a context of 1
a half% or 1% inflation to a 9%
inflation economy the results from those
relatively robust tests end up as uh
less than accurate followup followup um
so the are the are the discount rate
rates
specifically set in these tests I mean
does it say specifically that you must
use a discount rate of 1% or does it or
does it say you know what the prevailing
discount rate is well the the language
of the 2022 Bill said that you have to
feed in all of the subpart assumptions
that were in play in the last trianal
plan so that included the discount rates
in general terms and I um Mr chairman I
can take one or two more questions but
then I must go to the Senate if it's all
right yes uh we'll allow one more
question from representative Kaplan
thank you Mr chair and this is a quick
question following up on representative
M's question wouldn't it be easier to uh
place instead of eliminating uh the the
cost Effectiveness studies altoe
wouldn't it be easier to just amend the
statute by adding the need to uh take
into effect take into account the latest
discount rate studies just say you must
rates I would take that under advisement
to be sure that discount rates aren't
the only field of play that we were
struggling with as a commission in
applying the old um methodologies that
were in place in the last trianal plan
into this current trianal plan um that
would be worth a consideration but what
is attractive about representative
Harrington's approach is that really
leaves it even more open-ended and that
it short circuits the imposition of the
past elements of the
tests for future trianal plans it it
enables a more broad ranging broad
reaching examination of all the
assumptions that are presented the
amount of money that is involved is so
significant that when you have 97% of
the plans baked in and not capable of
modification by the commission not not
on overall spend but on allocation in
particular it it leads to
issues all right thank you uh can I
follow up with a quick followup though
make it quick yeah okay thank you Mr
chair but you in a previous uh question
you said you didn't really see problems
with the other elements of the
methodology so can you be more specific
about the the concerns you might have
with the other elements thank you well I
didn't necessarily say that I had no
problems in terms of uh the the the
thing is is that if you examine the the
language of the last bill and how it
was uh
applied in the context of this current
trianal plan as explain in the order
that I cited the legislature literally
locked into
place a lot of different spending
elements a lot of different plan
elements and it's hard to summarize and
I would recommend that everyone look
over the order and you can kind of get a
granular summary there but when you
freeze everything in place based on what
was done in the last trianal plan and
the commission is only allowed to review
3% of the spending for their different
modification elements it's very
difficult and if you for fast forward
that to yet another four-year time
Horizon if you're talking about from
2023 all the way to
2027 and that language of that
legislation is still in place all those
years later it can it would lead to a
lot of potential lost opportunities for
Energy Efficiency in New
Hampshire so um okay thank you we really
appreciate you uh coming to speak to the
committee this morning and we'll let you
go because we know you have other
responsibilities thank you thank you
very much Mr
chairman all right so we'll move on now
and I'll call the next uh folks who want
to speak with us and that's the depart
Department of energy represented by
assistant uh commissioner Chris Elms and
Dr Dean
yours good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Chris Elms I'm the Deputy
Commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of energy and I'm joined by
Dr Dina Reef who is a PhD Economist and
the director of natural gas regulation
at the department of energy so we are
here today in support of House Bill 1036
uh as you heard this bill would remove
the statutory
restrictions uh on the Pu to make any
changes to Energy Efficiency cost
Effectiveness tests going forward uh the
point that I'm going to discuss uh
briefly here is is similar to um our
testimony last week on House Bill 1617
which is frankly how far into the weeds
of of utility regulation does the
legislature want to dive so to give you
a little context and we heard a little
bit about this you know most of us I
think remember the puc's order in the
2021 through 2023 trianal Energy
Efficiency plan that led to House Bill
549 uh you know so in response to that
decision the legislature passed and and
Governor sonunu signed House Bill 549
and in that bill the legislature took
over control of the funding of of rapair
funded Energy Efficiency program
and also brought in these other
restrictions uh that we talked about
that we're talking about today uh you
know the department was supportive of
House Bill 549 and we worked hard with
representative Vos to both craft uh the
First Amendment to House Bill 549 which
was a retained Bill and then the more
exp expansive amendment that came in in
the Senate where these restrictions were
added and that was you know due in large
part because at the time the governor
and the house and the Senate um were all
very clear that they wanted to make sure
that the situation was resolved
expeditiously and with little room for
misinterpretation and that short-term
Focus uh was successful we were able to
resolve the issues but the circumstances
in in developing that bill and that
expedited process made a statute that is
probably overly restrictive and is a bit
clunky um you know most notably the bill
mandates coste Effectiveness as being
determined by uh you know the tests that
you see in statute there the granite
state test uh is is the primary test uh
a little history there the granite state
test was worked on and analyzed by a
benefit cost working group that was
directed by the Pu to file
recommendations on costeffective Energy
Efficiency programs uh and that test was
adopted by the Pu in late 2019 December
2019 uh this Committee in House Bill 549
did not review the those those
restrictions that were placed the the
amendment that you had passed in House
Bill 549 and the house pH just dealt
with the budgets those came in in the
Senate phase um you
know following House Bill 5 49's passage
the Pu approved a plan for the remainder
of the 21 through 23 triennial plan work
began on the 24 through 226 triennial
Energy Efficiency plan and as uh Mr
spidel referenced that order uh on
November 30th has set those programs for
the next three years this bill is really
about the next trienal plan 27 through
29 and and Beyond the work will start on
that in
2026 um now is the opportune time for us
to look at the statutory framework and
decide frankly whether or not the
legislature wants to be as involved uh
in in the intricacies of cost
Effectiveness tests um and Dr Reef is
going to spend some time talking about
uh the cost Effectiveness tests that are
in play in statute and some of those
factors like discount rates that we
heard from Mr spidel so I'm going to
thank you Deputy Commissioner Elms for
giving me the
floor I would like to begin by thanking
representative Vose the chair and all
the honorable members of the House
science technology and energy committee
for giving me this opportunity today to
speak the primary topic of my discussion
today is the the cost Effectiveness
tests namely the granite state test or
GST as I would be referring to them time
to time and the Total Resource cost test
or
trct as they are referenced in the
current version of the law RSA 374 df3
Roman numeral 6- a
subd what I would like to accomplish is
to bring certain Tech Technical and
practical observations to your
consideration all in light of how the
current version of the law has been
interpreted by various stakeholders and
how they have tried putting it into
practice a quick
caveat what I'm about to tell you is a
perspective informed by research and
observations by learning through
interactions with other stakeholders and
from relevant documents such as the puc
orders the Consulting reports from
working groups back in 2027 to 2021
period and learning from the
investigatory docket and Energy
Efficiency docket
processes as such I have relied upon
those documents and would do the very
best to provide appropriate
references
with that caveat let me allow let me
offer you an overview of the Granite
State and Total Resource cost
test at this point I would
kindly require or ask you request you to
look at page one of the handout that's
been
provided the granite state test is
identified as the primary test test
along with the Total Resource cost test
which is the secondary test essentially
they are the benefit to cost ratios used
to identify if the benefits from
undertaking certain programs outweigh
their
costs leading to a recommendation for
adoption and implementation of those
programs and vice
versa the underlying principles for or
any benefit cost test generally speaking
are
two first the input to benefits and cost
should be similar meaning if benefits
from an input is captured the costs
incurred to achieve those benefits
should also be
captured and the same treatment should
be accorded in calculating the net
present value value of benefit and cost
streams when they span over multiple
years this generally implies that the
same discount Factor value be used for
discounting benefit and cost
streams the absence of adherence to
these principles would lead to a biased
benefit to cost ratio
outcomes this in turn would lead to
recommendation of programs which should
not be perhaps
implemented the relevant question
therefore are what does it mean in the
context of New Hampshire's Energy
Efficiency plan what input values are
included in the GST and trct tests to
see that please refer to page two of the
handout this page provides
a quick overview of the inputs in the
Total Resource cost test of version of
which was amended to become the granite
state test this is sourced from the
evaluation measurement and verification
working group recommendation back in
2019 the figure shows what components
are fed into these two
tests
as you can see the key differences are
two all utility system impacts were
adopted into the current granite state
test this includes among others the
active demand reduction Reduction
Program that now graduated from being a
pilot to a full program in the most
recent approved Energy Efficiency plan
2024 26
the other key difference is that all
participant impacts were excluded into
the primary granite state
test in the context of the benefit to
cost ratio what does that mean the
answer would require a little closer
attention to what makes up the benefits
and cost streams a summary is provided
on page three of your
handout
as you can
see towards the bottom of the
page between the Total Resource cost
test and the granite state test the cost
streams does not include any participant
cost however non energy benefits by plan
participants are captured in the benefit
stream as was mentioned on page 86 of
the proposed proposed and now approved
2024 2026 Energy Efficiency plan
proposed by The Joint
utilities this in indicates that the
fundamental principle underlying the
benefit to cost ratio test is not
necessarily reflected in the current
granite state test which is not a best
practice the other fundamental principle
underlying the benefit to to cost ratio
test is the consistent application of
the discount rate to both the benefit
and cost streams the discount rate
aligns the trickling benefit and cost
streams that are spread over multiple
years into the current year dollar
values simply put the higher the
discount rate the lower the Net Present
Value since today's dollars are
generally generally regarded more
valuable than the future
dollars as such the discount rate and
the inputs leading to the calculation
and or choice of the discount rate is
significantly important this generally
implies three things first the same
methodology and value should be used in
calculating the net present value for
both the benefit and cost streams
secondly attention care and effort
should be given to align the time frame
for inputs that are used in developing
the discount
rate and finally attention should be
accorded in selecting the appropriate
discount
rate please allow me to unpack a little
bit
more the first Criterion the
methodological consistency implies that
the same value of the discount rate be
used in The Net Present Value
calculation for both the benefit and the
cost streams the second Criterion the
alignment of time frame for inputs to
discount rate implies that efforts
should be exerted to align input values
that make up the nominal discount rate
the inflation rate and their use in
calcul calculating the real discount
rate generally speaking real discount
rate is the nominal discount rate minus
the inflation
rate taken together these
simply this these imply if one discount
rate value is used to calculate the net
present value of benefits and a separate
value is used to calculate the net
present value of cost
the resulting benefit to cost ratio and
therefore the derived recommendations
thereof would be less than accurate the
granite state test is misaligned in its
current application which was confirmed
by the utilities during the
hearings utilities confirmed that the
nominal cost stream is derived using
inflation adjusted system benefits
charge and local delivery adjustment
chars and the nominal benefit stream is
derived using the inflation adjusted
avoided energy supply cost from
2021 the utilities also confirmed that
while the real discount rate is used to
derive program benefits program costs
were discounted using the nominal
discount rate Additionally the timing of
the nominal discount rate is different
from that of the inflation rate while
utilities used prime rate from June
2023 as the nominal discount rate they
used quarter 1 of 2022 through quarter 1
of
2023 as input for calculating the
inflation
rate the majority of the commission
identified this
misalignment in their recent order the
methodological deficiencies and their
less than accurate
application in the current 2024 2026
Energy Efficiency plan was referenced
into that same order as well yet the
majority of the commission felt they
lacked the legal Authority to make any
meaningful
changes the third Criterion is
highlighted as I highlighted
earlier is the appropriateness of the
chosen discount rate it is clear that
the discount rate plays a pivotal role
in identifying right set of programs via
the granite state test the relevant
question here therefore is what discount
rate is
appropriate this was invoked to be
addressed
in in
[Music]
um in the commission Leed investigative
22042 where all interested stakeholders
stakeholders provided their
input um in the interest of time um if
you want me to summarize I can I can do
so and I I would like to have some
questions um that you you may have um I
do have a little bit of a lengthy
um testimony but I would um I can
summarize and we can go over to the next
phase or I can continue whichever way
you feel comfortable cheerful thank you
that was uh extremely Illuminating
testimony we appreciate you offering it
I do have one
question since Net Present Value seems
to be one of the big sticking points in
determining whether these calculations
of costs and benefits are correct or not
could you give us a quick summary as
quick as you can about what's wrong with
The Net Present Value chosen by the plan
implementers and what the Pu sees
as what the Net Present Value probably
should
be thank you for that question um in
Reading relevant documents um and in
particular the order from the Pu it
appeared to me that uh it is both the
choice of different rates and the time
frame
used um which were misaligned as I was
saying could lead to different values of
Net Present Value depending on whether
the same Net Present Value um that same
discount rate is applied to the benefits
and cost streams so the way it was um it
appears to have been done is that the
net present value for benefits may have
been
inflated relatively speaking to the cost
of uh how it was done so when you take
something which is which is a little bit
higher than uh the cost of it and you
try to um you try to find out a ratio of
that and trying to see if it is greater
than one it would generally lead to more
than one that is what that is
technically
trying not to be as technical as as it
is um that is essentially what it is
which it which basically um goes over to
the uh recommendation of the program but
there is a significant policy role in
determining how to approach it what to
take and um flexibility perhaps um by
the very people who are tasked with
doing that job is allow you to allows
them to do that job so my follow-up
question would be is it an
oversimplification to say that the time
frames used to calculate net present
value is the big issue
here I would generally agree with that
statement it would be oversimplified if
we get to that conclusion um however
having recognized that I would say that
what is required is essentially some
sort of a policy guidance that is
enabled through the statutes that gives
the flexibility to the authority who are
tasked with doing that or performing
that job
um that's that would be it good thank
um representative muns has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for uh
taking my question um from your
testimony it it appears that um the the
granite state test is basically a flawed
methodology there are a lot of problems
with it um you know the fact that if I
understood you correctly that they're
using two different discount rates one
for benefits and one for costs I mean I
I understand that and that's that is a
problem um my I guess my question for
you is is that methodology defined
somewhere in
statute um and um you know you know that
somewhere so I to to ju just jump in on
the question of whether or not you know
the test itself is flawed there are no
tests that are going to be perfect and
and there may or may be may may or may
not be you know issues or misalignments
that Dr brief identified those are in
essence policy decisions in a lot of
ways and those choice of discount rates
are decisions that had been made uh at
some point along the line uh to to trade
some flaws for another so it's not to
say that the granite state test is is is
not the appropriate test and and before
this uh house spell 549 passed it was
the prevailing cost Effectiveness test
uh at the commission but it is to say
that nothing is nothing is perfect and
that you know as as referenced by both
Dr AR and uh Mr Mr spidel um there there
probably needs to be greater flexibility
for the commission and this is the
Commission in
2026 uh to to be able to look uh at at
those adjustments um the second part of
the question I'm going to let Dr AR
address um thank you for that I I would
just simply add to other factors any
decision is taken at the time off with
the available information best available
information the test is not generally
flawed what information is fed into it
and how is really the question and there
are policy implications of that um and
policy decisions are to be taken that is
what we are focusing on and just to
answer the part of the question that we
didn't touch on the granite state test
is not defined in statute it is
referenced in in that statute um and it
it has been taken to mean the order that
approved it and then the uh working
group report and the um the the research
and Analysis that went into the approval
of that 2019 uh order F
followup followup um so I I think I
understand what you're saying but I
guess the the one question I have now is
that um you said it both of you said on
several occasions that um the test
reflects policy decisions that were made
well who made those policy
decisions uh well the the Commission in
in approving that order in 2019 and the
legislature in putting uh the granted
state test in Statute in House Bill 549
and that's part of why you know in my
discussions with repres representative
Harrington to uh bring up this bill um
and as I referenced earlier those policy
decisions were not thoroughly discussed
uh at the time of House Bill 549 going
through the legislature and being passed
there wasn't a ton of public input there
wasn't a ton of legislative input and I
think it's clear that that happened for
a reason uh to to you know uh stabilize
a situation but um we wanted to bring
this forward so the legisl
would both be aware and and be able to
consider uh these issues and whether or
not they want to be responsible for them
or let the Pu do what they're paid to do
okay thank you for that representative
campan and representative Corman I would
like you both to remember the questions
you want to
ask I am going to recess this public
hearing until
11:00 that's approximately 12 minutes
from now and the reason I'm doing that
is because I'm going to open a public
1078 relative to first responder
organization access to wireless tower
collocation I'm going to ask the prime
sponsor representative Mark PR to
introduce this legislation to
US Representative PR sorry to keep you
waiting so
long thank you I appreciate you making
Provisions because I have somewhere else
to be I'd rather be here but I have to
be somewhere else so introducing uh
thank you chairman and the members of
the
committee uh my name is Mark PR
um from Hillsboro 15 which is Manchester
w 8 so I come bringing this bill to be
able to collocate first responder radio
equipment basically an antenna on a
tower along with the equipment that goes
with it um down
below
um not being a 100% expert so I come
from I work for the town of eping as
their deputy chief uh we are having a
lot of radio communication issues out
there we're hoping to be able to revamp
our system at some point and as you know
out towards the Sea Coast there are not
a lot of Hills to stick an antenna on or
tall buildings so we're going to need
multiple locations for our antennas so
this is what is really driving this
bill but I would imagine that a lot of
other jurisdictions would benefit from
being able to have uh the ability to
collocate on towers that are already up
and
available uh originally I asked for the
top 20 feet but as talking to Department
of Safety which he'll be um is behind me
and we'll be
um testifying that may not always be the
best spot for our antenna due to FCC
regulations and such so maybe we're just
looking for the ability to C out K that
in the spot that might be better suited
for us um and I'm okay with
that uh we talked about priority and
that I have it as local city
County State
and he brought up a good point that I
didn't even think of that as a town
having the first priority or right of
refusal they might say yeah we don't
have anything right right away but that
might be great in 10 years and lock up
that space where the state could come in
and put a department of safety
interoperability um radios that would
probably serve the area better better so
maybe that can be negotiated that the
priority goes to the local first but if
they don't have a plan they can't lock
it up and and it the Statewide
interoperability committee should be
looking at that and making that
decision and he also brought up that you
know maybe they'll be charged
for collocating but I look at it and I
know some other towns already have it in
their Charters
um or what have you
that it's the cost of doing business and
we get to locate one antenna or whatever
up there as a cost of doing business and
with that I'll end my my testimony
because I know you got a lot of left on
that other bill and I'll take a couple
of quick questions I guess okay thank
you representative PR questions for
representative PR Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question um I I I happen to
ask my own fire department in lary about
this bill and they they were in favor of
it uh because their rationale was it
would really help with their
negotiations when they try and locate
first responder equipment um on any any
new new tower in in your case is it just
a matter of help negotiations or is this
more of a matter of uh you have some
critical dead spots that you can't get
to because of lack of this type of a
bill we have more dead spots than a
cemetery so
um we really need to be able to spread
our antennas out to cover those spots
and and I know trying to put up a tower
takes a while so if there's one already
there that will work for us I think that
would be great I know I had some other
fire chiefs that were going to come but
because it's snowing and they have to
stay in town so when the school bus
rolls over or whatever they're there
well I know there are 39 cemeteries in
eing so that's a lot of dead spots yes
yes there is further questions
representative liwicki has one uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um who owns these towers and if
um we are to essentially take of you
know demand that a private owner on a
private property uh give up some
worthwhile space on their thing on their
towel would this not be a
taking
I guess but um I know especially if
they're putting up a tower that uh this
might help the town say if you want a
town it a tower in our town you have to
give us a
space further questions representative
McGee thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Pro for taking my
question and for being here today um I
just took a quick glance at what was
written out in terms of um testimony on
the bill and I note that we have uh uh
legislative affairs and safety weighing
in on the practicality of implementing
the bill as written they're basically
talking about legal issues um and
practical issues in terms of there's a
problem you want to solve and this is
the vehicle you're giving us to solve it
have you had any conversations with them
around how practical it is to use this
particular solution to get to the ends
that you're seeking so I've had some I
just spoke with the Department of Safety
out in the hall uh nobody's really
reached out to me beforehand so and and
I understand I don't know enough about
all of this and that's where the
committee comes in I know in my
committees we're we're doing some of
this work on some of the other bills
that people don't really have all the
background that they need so I'm open to
absolutely trying to fix this to make at
work as best we
can thank
you and additional questions sorry about
the mic
partiall thank you chair and thank you
for your uh testimony today um can you
tell me we are talking about Wireless
and Broadband uh access for emergency
services Noble idea um how redundant is
the W would the wireless service be
generally speaking I know every
situation is different but how redundant
would it be to what's already there
available in Broadband which I also
understand is not always Dependable can
you speak to that so we're not always
using broadband and stuff we're using
land mobile radio uh I know in our fire
World those radios are more rugged than
anything else and running into burning
buildings
with less sturdy equipment doesn't
usually work and yes I know some of our
radios have that ability to use
broadband and
stuff but they're like at four times the
cost of a regular
radio followup followup I just one this
so I understand now we're talking about
uh where the First Responders is the
point of access we're actually doing the
service not uh the first responder
Network correct okay thank you for
clarifying that
Thomas thank you uh I'm over here um
yeah I don't I don't get to see you guys
very much but um my question is to the
best of your ability or to the best of
your knowledge have any First
Responders organizations been denied
space on a a wire or been denied space
or the request for an
antenna I have not heard
that but
um not
personally I've had heard it in general
that they asked didn't get on what have
you I have heard like uh it's either
East Kingston or Kensington has it in
their Town Charter or whatever they used
uh to have that
ability to have a spot on the
tower uh it was East Kingston cuz the
Chief came to me and said I forgot to
ask for a top portion of the
Tower and I'm down at like 20 feet off
the ground which really didn't help me
at all whereas if I had it 60 feet
probably would have been better yeah
okay thank you okay I'm going to suggest
that we hold our further questions for
the people who will testify after
representative PR representative PR
needs to be over at the fire academy so
we want to thank you for introducing
this bill and uh we own it now so we'll
we'll take it from here thank you thank
you for the uh help you bet okay so I'm
going to recess this public hearing
until
11:15 and I'm going to resume the public
hearing on the previous bill which is
House Bill 1036
we have one more person who wants to
testify on this
bill and I will bring back the
department of energy if there are
questions for those individuals but
first let's hear from Mike lcot of
eversource to get his perspective on
this
legislation
uh thank you for the record Michael Lata
representing eversource also think it's
important probably to point out I am not
an economist just when we get to the Q&A
section um eversource is opposed to the
the legislation as introduced uh we do
support keeping the current cost benefit
test in statute um for use in future
proceedings uh I think is important to
note that the granite state test was uh
developed by a broad set of stakeholders
in 2018 and 2019 that included the
utilities included the consumer Advocate
um included at the time Public Utilities
Commission staff uh as well as numerous
other stakeholders uh involved in the
Energy Efficiency uh dockets uh that was
approved by commission order in
2019 um those orders do have the the
effect of Law and so that has been the
test that has been in use since uh I
know it was discussed the legislative of
history of codifying the granite state
test and the current uh cost benefit
test uh so I won't cover that but I I
did want to speak to the benefits of
keeping um the cost benefit the existing
cost benefit test uh in statute which is
uh I know this Committee in the past
when uh reviewing House Bill 549 heard a
lot from uh uh contractors private
business about the the necessity for
consistency uh in the programming and so
uh for the utilities having this cost
benefit uh codified into the statute
provides us with
consistency uh we have a knowledge of
what programs will qualify what programs
will not uh where to put resources in
terms of of additional funding that
consistency allows us to um uh structure
programs when we're filing for submitt
to the commission um our three-year
trienal plan as was referenced we we
just got approval of the most recent uh
plan uh without that uh consistency
there is uncertainty uncertainty around
what programs will qualify um whether
the a commission could um sort of take a
sharp left or a sharp right turn uh
after a planed submitt which would
require uh significant revisions to a
plan the uh contractor Community are
customers who rely on these programs
businesses that rely on these programs
vendors that build up their businesses
around providing these Services um that
that uh
inconsistency uh about a different cost
benefit test or radical changes to to
the cost benefit test uh impacts them
and so uh for those reasons we support
uh keeping the existing uh uh statutory
language and uh would encourage the
committee uh not to move forward with
the bill as as introduced happy to
answer any questions thank you to the
best of my ability
Mr we'll try not to put you on the spot
too much question wise
but the first question that occurs to me
is that this bill doesn't remove the
granite state test or any other test
from
statute and the issue seems to me to be
the inputs that are being used by these
tests
to do the cost benefit analysis that
they purport to do if the inputs are
inconsistent then can you agree that
maybe some modifications need to be made
so that we can be relatively certain
that the cost benefit analysis is an
accurate one uh
so want to make sure I'm staying in in
my non-economist Lane um um so so you
are correct it it does not strike the
the grant at state test or the current
cost benefit test from the statue but
what it does say is that uh the
commission is not required to use those
on a going forward basis so um you know
I think it's important to acknowledge
sort of the regulatory backdrop that
this uh legislation is being offered uh
which is you know the last triennial
plan um the commission uh I would say in
their their data requests in their order
uh voiced skepticism voiced a level of
of desire to make we'll say significant
changes to the cost benefit test um and
so that is is sort of the backdrop the
lens by which we are uh the utility uh
that eversource excuse me is reviewing
this language through um so you know if
you think about the granted state test
as as a a framework a cost benefit
framework and here's where I don't want
to get uh provide an accurate
information or or um you know misspeak
uh but certainly when we're structuring
the programs you know I I think
inputs uh to that framework are subject
to change are subject to evaluation so
um what is in in the statute uh does
point back to the commission order which
uh you know to representative M's
question you know where did this come
from points back to um the the product
of that working group in 2019 2018 and
so certainly is it possible to to review
you know the inputs to that overall
framework um you know I I believe that
is is possible I think it is I would
want to touch based with our subject
matter experts though to to give you a
better
answer further questions
Vice chair Thomas has a question thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question so I understand that any
business likes
consistency whether or not a policy is
good or bad whatever it is they like
consistency so my question would be at
what point do you feel
that A change is needed um to keep up
with the times in order to avoid doing
the same thing over and over again when
conditions have changed what would you
recommend uh or would you just say keep
it forever that way yeah it's it's a
fair question so I think first and
foremost um as expressed through the um
trianal plan we we are supportive of the
granite state test we we do think that
that is an appropriate test so uh you
know not just moving forward with a bad
test because that's what we have to do
um and you know I know the department
Express
concerns as well although I I did hear
them say you know this is not a a
fundamentally flawed test so um so you
know I I think
um if it is determined that there are
issues with the test um then you know a
looking at how the granite state test
was developed to begin with which was a
rigorous lengthy stakeholder development
process um you know at some Future Point
uh could the
legislature direct the the you know
Redevelopment a a similar stakeholder
process to to review and make
adjustments you know that might be
appropriate at a future date um I think
what we're suggesting is is now is not
that
time followup thank you for the followup
so I I believe we her testimony that uh
uh um doe did not feel like the test was
actually flawed it was just the data
that was used in the formulas uh might
need to be looked at from time to time
so wouldn't you agree that there ought
to be a mechanism in order to if you
want to keep the same test of course but
to to update data that that is put into
the formula how how would you how would
you go about keeping that data fresh and
updated
again I don't want to you know get past
my depth here so um you know I'd like uh
to touch Spas with the folks who are
involved in you know the data inputs um
how how they administer or apply I
should say the granite state test to to
our um uh proposals on on you know
whether they agree with I think there's
a fundamental question that there's
there's an issue there so I'd be Happ
happy to provide an answer um back to to
you and the
committee representative Harrington has
a question thank you Mr chairman thank
you for point of order point of order Mr
chairman yes represent representative
Harrington introduced the bill and spoke
on the bill my understanding is that
when we speak on the bill we are not uh
to be asking questions you are correct
okay thank you for addressing that point
of order I'll withdraw my recognition of
Representative Harrington representative
McGee has a question thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mr Lata for enduring us
one more time um I to my colleague's
point uh to the left um representative
from londondary that there he was
questioning a mechanism and what struck
me in the conversations that have been
had from that chair so far is that the
process is what has actually changed
because the chair and myself were
members of the easy board up until
recently when it was dissolved and many
of these conversations around uh how we
were approaching the funding were taken
care of in that very robust and
long-term stakeholder group and so that
piece is not available anymore um and my
understanding is that when subcommittees
through the easy board actually worked
to bring something to the Public
Utilities Commission in terms of a
trianal plan they also engaged an
economist in order to substantiate the
inputs that they were providing so can
you speak to how much the process has
changed since the utilities are now I
guess working together to try and come
up with that plan devoid of the
additional stakeholder process that used
utilized so as you said representative
and thank you for the question um uh
certainly there has been a change that
the easy board um as of last year was
was abolished and as you pointed out the
easy board had
provided um the utilities with a A you
know recognized venue for stakeholder
input uh as you said there were
different subcommittees of the easy
board that were uh put into place to you
know look at funding mechanisms look at
at cost benefit tests um on a going
forward basis and and those were used uh
as part of the last triennial plan um so
on a going forward basis um uh you know
when we're putting together our next
trienal plan in in two years um you know
we will have to find a a replacement a
substitute for um that public
stakeholder uh inputs that the easy
board had provided and certainly you
know
it's I would would say a known universe
of of interested parties uh subject to
expansion and other input
but I think it would be uh probably more
on a an ad hoc basis of bringing the
utilities as we start developing these
plans bringing in stakeholders and
having very similar conversations and
discussions just outside of that um
established easy board
framework followup so my follow-up
question would be it sounds like where
we're having a bit of a breakdown is in
whose assumptions we're using as our
inputs
and that there are assumptions being
thrown around in terms of the plan not
being right and discussions around how
do we get to the correct assumptions so
can you give us in your testimony here
today um eversource's position in terms
of how we make those
determinations um do do you have an
economist on staff who's working on this
type of thing in order to give a
qualified opinion on when an assumption
is being made whether it's accurate in
order to get to a cost benefit or um you
know some of the testimony that we heard
earlier about perhaps they're not being
the best inputs where are the inputs
coming from yeah I I I think the the
best approach and again thank you for
the question is um I I would be happy to
um knowing that this is the public
hearing but have our our Energy
Efficiency staff that puts together um
the triennial plans we can provide sort
of a an explainer like a onepage of how
they go about doing that uh selecting
program funding how the cost benefit
tests are are applied and and the
Assumption so I think that would
probably be the the best approach is I
would be happy to follow up with that
and provide it to to the
committee thank you but there is rigor
thank you there is rigor to your point
yes all right
question uh thank you Mr chairman and
thanks for taking my question
uh you seem to focus on consistency and
I just wondered is would it be fair to
say that you have a concern that the Pu
adequately um I think it is fair to say
that uh the having the cost benefit test
in statute provides consistency uh on a
going forward basis and removing the re
requirement to use that any commission
um it is subject subject to change and
so that inserts an amount of uncertainty
into the process going forward I think
that's
fair follow
up yeah but I I I mean I wonder if you
would you know concede that if the Pu
does value
consistency that any changes they make
you know they will you know that will be
part of the
consideration
I I I would agree that if a uh
commission excuse me commission values
consistency then they would uh to use
use the phrase you know use a light
touch with changes acknowledging that uh
radical changes would would have
negative impacts although you know we
have seen past orders where there have
been radical changes that they uh had uh
suggested and then or adopted by order
and then the the legislature had sort of
stepped in with Senate uh House Bill 549
realigned okay representative Thomas has
a question um actually I think I it's a
question for the doe so are you going to
call them back up thank
you thank you uh Mr Lata I'd like
to reflect on the fact that
representative Corman and representative
Kaplan have further questions for the do
doe so I'd like the doe to uh return to
the table if you would please we do have
one more person who wants to testify
after the doe and then we need to resume
the public hearing
on HB
1078 so uh thank you to commissioner
Elms and Mr Arif for returning to the
podium here I have a quick question and
that
is can the Pu change inputs we've
discussed earlier that inputs seem to be
to these tests seem to be an issue can
they change those now so I don't want to
speak for the Public Utilities
Commission because uh Mr spidel left um
the way that that the majority of the uh
Commission in in their recent order
interpreted the statute uh they could
not make any changes to the cost
Effectiveness test so
that Al that fact alone regardless of
whether or not stakeholders uh or
interveners believe that they could
change inputs it shows that there is at
the very least a lack of legislative
Clarity on whether or what the pu's
authority is as it comes as it pertains
to cost Effectiveness tests I do also
just want to um apologize I did cut off
uh Dr AR earlier for for you know in his
testimony I I don't think we would
necessarily want to say that the only
potential issue or uh area of of
discussion here is the input I think
there was a you know OB uh he talked
about an asymmetry um in the benefit
cost ratio there are other
considerations that go into uh you know
determining these things and and frankly
that's a little bit why this bill is
coming
forward you know I I cut uh Dr AR off
because you know he he had I think
another five or six pages of testimony
to get through uh we we we could talk
all day about these issues and and as uh
Mr lcot indicated there was a lot of
work that went into the development of
the grand state test future iterations
changes anything like that under this
statute are going to have to happen
through the legislature and so if the
legislature wants to take on that
responsibility um just just know that
there there is a a great deal of
discussion uh that should happen um as
these as these plant move forward um and
and it's to
you is Mr AR's testimony available to
the committee uh we can make it make it
available great that would be
wonderful
representative
um Corman has a question for you
actually thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question uh Mr Arif um
your your
testimony scared me a little bit uh in
that you're you're saying that no test
is perfect and I certainly understand
that there are a lot of assumptions
being made in a test and when even a
discount rate is really a guess as to
what's going to happen in the
future so I'm a little concerned that
you know perhaps we get a situation
where we do a cost benefit test and it
comes out
1.02 or
998 and we make it a decision on that
it's greater than one it's less than one
but actually there's a margin of error
here should these tests include a margin
possible thank you for the question
representative Corman um I apologize my
testimony was not or never meant to be
concerning or uh daunting but uh it it
uh if I may speak for just myself not
necessarily doe just as a granite stator
myself it did scare me when the
commission said that they could only
opine on 3% of a quarter of a billion
dollar which turns out out to be just
about merely like you know if my memory
supports me 200 out of $253
million
$246 million they were silent on it the
majority of the commission order was and
there got to be a reason why they were
and that is probably under the
microscope here rather than like you
know there are nuances to answer your
question specifically all tests have
margins of errors and they that is by a
um definition it the construction of
these tests takes into account of those
and those are rigorous in a enough uh
themselves um so yes but those margins
of errors in a way speak to the policy
scope and to what
degree uh The Authority or the system
put in place um and the stakeholders
interpret those margins of error is
really the question under the microscope
over here um as Deputy Commissioner Elms
was saying to uh essentially the the
most recent order from the
Pu um looking into the proposal that was
put before them appears to have been
very uncomfortable in opining on the 97%
of the overall budget um the question is
why
and uh whether the enabling statutes
allows them and all the stakeholders
Frankly Speaking um to voice their
concern and on the aggregate make an
informed decision that is in the benefit
of the Granite Staters is really the
question follow up thank you all right
so you you said that the the uh margin
of error is is already taken into
account in the test yet the result of
the test is a number if I'm not mistaken
right it is a ratio it's not a ratio
with a plus or minus or anything like
that so how how do you take the margin
of error into account and still come up
number that's an excellent question I
would acknowledge that having said so
though what we are really driving
to is the set of assumptions and the
margin of error around those assumptions
and whether they're acceptable or not is
the question having accepted all those
premises we can always come up with a a
number and I do agree with you what what
I if my memory again supports me the the
communication line was that the benefit
cost ratio last time around spits out
number of
2.11 meaning that every dollar spent in
terms of cost gives a
$211 in terms of benefits if the
underlying assumptions are not correct
and the the ri rigor is missing in
coming up with that particular figure
the whole output or outcome
is um less than accurate and that's all
I wanted to capture by trying to provide
specific areas where uh all these
stakeholders in their own admission
provided those responses and we wanted
to just bring it over to your attention
for your
consideration thank you to
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
gentleman for taking my question um
commissioner Elms you you you seem to be
throwing the ball into the legislature's
court by saying
that you know this is something that we
can choose to take on or not choose to
take on and then that you know there are
very
deep technical questions that we might
have or not have expertise on but given
the testimony that we're hearing and the
uncertainty that seems to be implicit in
the coste effectiveness process in
general and the policy implications of
those uncertainties how can we not get
involved and given that uh wouldn't you
agree that this might be more
appropriate for a study commission
rather than
a wholesale removal of the cost the cost
effective assessments process thank you
I I I really do appreciate that question
and and I would I wouldn't characterize
it as I'm throwing it into your court uh
what I'm going to tell you is this ball
right now because of the statute is
fully in your court um it's it's there
and you took it on in House Bill
549 um you
know the reason and and I I'll just Echo
what I said in in House Bill 16 17's um
testimony the reason that every state
has a Public Utilities Commission uh or
a dpu or whatever you know they call it
uh is because these are very um complex
time consuming uh processes that involve
experts and stakeholders and a really
collaborative process a study commission
you know there there does need to be a
really deep look at what we're doing
essentially a pu is going to do that
work of the study commission that's why
we have a pu
and I and I'll just say you know to to
whatever discomfort folks have with the
current makeup of of the executive
branch energy apparatus right uh the
chairman of the Pu his term is up in
July of 2025 the commissioner of
Energy's term is up in December of 2025
and the Deputy Commissioner is up in
August of 2025 a new governor is going
to make all of those appointments um
this legislature could look very
different the reason this isn't really
about any individual people or left or
right or whoever's you know in charge
it's frankly what is the appropriate
statutory framework uh that that we want
to apply the legislature right now has
made a decision it is the
legislator if if we think that this is a
job that might be more appropriate for
the Public Utilities Commission I would
suggest moving forward with this bill or
it representative Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um I think
you may have answered answered my
question but I just want to clarify so
you said that if we if the legislature
wants to make or if the state of New
Hampshire wants to make any changes to
the granite state test it has to be done
through the legislature is that
correct I I think I would be fair to say
that that is the interpretation of a
majority of the Public Utilities
Commission follow
up yes go ahead so there's no team that
owns this is this is blowing my mind
there's no team te that owns this test
that can update it as needed on a
regular basis it has to come before the
legislature for every single update to
this test that's
crazy that is the interpretation that
that led to us bringing forward a bill
that would say that the legislature
might want to bring in more flexibility
so I I would agree with you yeah okay
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you uh for
being here and for your test
so one of the things that strikes me
about what I'm hearing you saying uh
from from the the hearing
table uh is that the concern is that uh
the most significant portion of the
money that's put aside for Energy
Efficiency into the New Hampshire saves
program is not something that the Pu has
the ability to question or modify
and I I I guess my take would be that
the legislature has kind of spoken on
the fact that we want Energy Efficiency
we want the New Hampshire saves program
to have that funding and to make those
changes because um regardless of how
that uh how the testing results in a
number uh which may have variables to it
um we do have sufficient evidence that
there is a significant benefit to
creating the negawatts that the consumer
Advocate tells us about all the time
right the energy that we don't use is a
savings it's a saving across the system
and so I think there's a there may be a
disconnect between us as to what we are
trying to achieve whether we are trying
to uh get at that money in order to say
it should be less or we need to save it
or we don't want to charge people that
or whether we see that
that is sort of the one and only way
that we've agreed that we would like to
have a benefit across the system for
everybody and it's a great point and
it's one I agree with and and I think
what what is very clear in in statute is
that costeffective Energy Efficiency is
a policy of the State of New Hampshire
but the cost effective is an important
part of it we don't do Energy Efficiency
for energy efficiency's sake and so the
question would be and I'm not saying
this in the context that the GST is this
but if our cost Effectiveness test
becomes flawed or has flaws in inputs
that are unable to be changed it just
calls into question that first part the
cost effective part of cost effective
Energy Efficiency so we agree with you
this is about Energy Efficiency and and
and getting it done the right way it's
just making sure that we have the
flexibility to ensure that those
programs that we're undertaking are
costeffective and again the granite
state test might be there but if if if
there Comes A Time 2026 and Beyond where
where we don't see that it's now very
inflexible and we don't have the ability
legislature have a followup followup and
I appreciate that answer I think that's
um makes perfect sense the thing that I
question the bill about though is
whether we eliminate the tools that we
have before we have figured out what the
tools are that we should be going to
because what it does is it not only
gives flexibility it gives far too much
leeway without any uh of the
legislator's input in terms of what
would be a relevant cost test let's
avoid the temptation to ask the same
question in a different way I I I would
just say on that point um this would go
back to the statutory framework that
existed before March of
2022 um you know I and and frankly uh
what house bill 549 was in reaction to a
perceived um abrupt change in a negative
way for the legislature stakeholders the
governor whoever and should a commission
not use the the appropriate
considerations that remains within the
purview of the legislature to come in
and and fix it again right I I would
hope that folks saw what happened with
House Bill 549 and would use that to
help guide you know future decision
making thank you representative muns do
you have a new question to ask I I I
think think
so we'll see uh thank you Mr chairman um
I want to I want to just follow up on
the um uh the back and forth you had
with u representative Wendy Thomas
um um if if if any of the parameters of
the granite state test or the Total
Resource test or any of these other
tests uh if it's your view or and the
pu's view that
that can only be changed by
legislation or by the
legislature should part of this bill
then be some kind of enabling power to
the Pu to be able to
change to to change the model as needed
to reflect things like changes in
inflation rate and discount rate I mean
should we be should we be giving you the
authority that it sounds like you want
to be able to kind of make some changes
to a model that you know seems to be
working it's just that some of the the
the inputs are not
correct yeah yeah you you could you
could uh add language to further clarify
that changes could be made to the
granite state test but and I I think it
might be the view of some that the
granite state test is the collection of
of of its you know component parts right
and that by being able to if if the law
just said you have to have something
called called the granite state test but
the Pu can change the P the the granite
state test to whatever they want it to
be in essence that's the same as
removing the bill but if you I I guess
to your point maybe it's more about
specifying specifically what can be
changed or what can be amended that's
something you could do frankly it it
might just be you know easier to let the
commission do what the commission's
meant to do followup okay so yeah I mean
I think I I hear what you're saying that
you know the test includes a whole a
whole bunch of different things but um I
mean yeah maybe we can limit it by
saying you know you have the authority
you know you have to still do the basic
basic modeling that's being done now but
you know in terms of specific things
like um do you use inflation adjusted
you know costs or not um and what
inflation rate do you use and what
discount discount rate do you use and
you have the authority to change that I
mean some something like that sure and
and and if you'll indulge me a little
bit on it I think we would be okay with
you know we're we're just happy to have
brought this bill forward so that you
know that you have this discussion you
can have the conversation we would be
happy to participate in whatever
development of language this commission
or excuse me committee wants us to do
you know we're I think we're clear on
where we stand on the on the bill I
think as written it's it gets the job
done uh but if you do have any desire to
further work on language we'd be happy
to weigh in on that okay we can't can't
come up with a new bill during a public
hearing uh it's an important discussion
to have and I'm sure the committee
during a work session will have a
further discussion on what to do but we
appreciate you being here to give us
your perspective and for bringing this
issue to our
attention so with that I'm going to ask
Mr Don Cree to come forward to to give
us his perspective on this legislation
and Mr Cree I'd ask you to be sensitive
to the fact that we're under some severe
time constraints here this morning we've
already recessed one public hearing and
we need to reopen that uh so please if
you could just confine your remarks
to the most important nugget of what you
want us to know we'd appreciate that uh
thank you Mr chairman for the record I'm
Don Cree the consumer Advocate you all
know me you didn't have to tell me that
Mr chairman I could tell what you were
thinking from the expression on your
face uh I uh regret to say that I oppose
House Bill 1036 and urge you to itl this
bill uh this is a pretty straightforward
scenario uh in its order of November
12th
20121 the commission ridiculed and I
think that's a fair assessment the
commission ridiculed the granite state
test and said it had no intention of
applying it or considering it ever again
then when you adopted House Bill 549 you
overruled the commission and said no you
must use the granite state test it was
after all the product of a very long
arduous and thoughtful process uh that
was conducted by the benefit cost
working group which by the way operated
not under the egis of the easy board but
under the egis of the Public Utilities
Commission itself and I think it's
important to bear that in mind
um there has been I think some
misunderstandings proliferating at this
hearing about what the quote unquote
inputs to the granite state test really
are and I think it is important to
reread the pu's most recent order which
went down on a two to one basis the
majority of the puc made absolutely
clear to you that if you tell the Pu
that it is no longer required to use the
granite state test it will dispense with
that test largely for the same reasons
that it gave in 2021 all of this talk
about inputs to the granite state test
is I think confusing or misleading in
the following sense what underlies the
granite state test is a thousand page
document called the technical reference
manual and what that thousand-page
document does does which you can check
out because it is on the website of the
puc under docket
2092 is it goes through measure by
measure by measure exactly what each of
those measures is capable of achieving
by way of savings that's that is the
input that is the critical one for the
granite state test that does change from
time to time as circumstances meaning
technology economic conditions that sort
of thing change so the Pu is capable
of changing its analysis about how to
apply the granite state test based on
changed
conditions uh Dr Arif said well he was
concerned about the Pu only being able
to affect 3% of the hundreds of millions
of dollars in uh rate payer funds that
go toward Energy Efficiency and I I
guess with all due respect to him as an
attorney I I have to disagree I I don't
think the Pu the majority of the Pu was
correct to reach that conclusion I know
that the only attorney on the Pu
disagreed with that legal conclusion and
I disagree with it as
well in my opinion excuse
me the argument that the Pu is having
with the rest of the world about the
granite state test really comes down to
the discount rate that you apply in
order to take a benefit stream savings
that sometimes extends up to 30 years
and bringing that up to a Net Present
Value so it can reasonably and
responsibly be compared to costs and the
granite state test calls for a low
social discount rate and the important
thing to remember about discount rates
is there really is no empirical data
that supports the choice of any discount
rate in my opinion to be perfectly
straightforward with you I would say
that if you like rate payer funded
Energy Efficiency you apply a low
discount rate and if you think it's bad
public policy then you apply a high
discount rate and the Public Utilities
Commission at least its majority has
made clear to you that it does not like
rate payer funded Energy Efficiency it
is as simple as that all the talk about
inputs is I think uh misleading and is
something to think carefully about
before you legislate now you don't have
to take my word for any of this and I
doubt you will I'm just trying to
introduce some doubt into the discourse
that you've heard from some of the uh
prior prior Witnesses um in light of the
Chairman's uh suggestion that I be as
brief as possible I think I'll just
leave it there and maybe there'll be a
few questions thank you I do appreciate
that your nugget seems to be that the
real issue here is a low versus a high
discount rate and that's something the
committee needs to give some serious
thought to I I agree so further
questions representative Corman thank
you Mr chairman and thank you Mr Cree
for taking my question I actually think
I want to ask you the same question I
asked Mr Arif uh given that there's
uncertainty and we apply these tests and
get a number rather than some sort of
reasonable
range are these tests really that
helpful if we're actually just going
going to use a number I'm actually not
sure that I agree that there is as much
uncertainty as you think there is I mean
you are looking at a future stream of
benefits and even though I have a
crystal ball on my desk at the office
even I can't AG uh predict the future
with accuracy but I I I think most of
the time the results are pretty
objectively verifiable because they all
are derived from that technical
reference manual and I'd invite you is a
person who loves to crunch numbers to
take a look at that the other point I
would make about the way this works
under house bill 549 is that when you
get to those measures that fall right on
the line right around either a little
above or a little below one the statute
says that there actually is a secondary
test that the Pu must apply as a kind of
a check on the first number so I think
that is the way you chose to deal with
those uncertainties to the extent that
they exist in House Bill 549 9 and to
the best of my knowledge no conditions
have changed since you acted two years
ago that justify a different result
ago additional questions I'd like to
move
on so thank you uh Mr Cree for being
here and with that I'd like to end this
public hearing on House Bill
1036 and now we can reopen the public
hearing on House Bill
1078 and I would like to call forward
the well the letter from the Department
of of uh safety
was um signed by Mark
doy is that a typo that is a typo oh
okay well my my mistake I'm sorry I read
the typo and thought that that was
actually your name but I guess it's Mark
Doyle is that correct that is correct Mr
chair thank you well thank you for being
here let's hear what you have to say
thank you very much Mr chair and and
good morning folks of the science
technology and energy committee um
regarding
hb178 I'd like to speak to that for just
a few moments and give you a perspective
of the Department of Safety which takes
a neutral position relative to this bill
however there are several major
considerations that first responder
organizations will need to address
interested in collocating on a
commercially owned wireless tower
technically speaking the highest spot in
the uppermost 20 ft of any new antenna
mount or Tower isn't always considered
the best
location from an engineering perspective
the bill as written doesn't provide for
an exception forcing first respond
organizations only have access to that
section of the tower should the bill be
modified to read that space would be
guarant guaranteed on any new tower that
would provide greater flexibility for a
reversed respond organization wishing to
expand or enhance their radio
communications networks as an example
the state of New Hampshire occupies
several Towers in Northern New Hampshire
where access to the uppermost section
would be prohibited by the Federal
Communications Commission that's due to
potential interference with Canada and
will require extensive coordination with
what industry candidate calls themselves
for our or Department of Safety radio
network to have the necessary space on
those locations currently for us to have
location space on those towers for an
appropriate emergency communications we
settled at under 100 ft at those
locations to satisfy those requirements
and also as written The Spill specifies
that there is an order of priority by
which space would be potentially
allocated on a new tower specifically
the local municipality the town would
have the highest priority or first right
of refusal and if so would the town be
able to hold that space indefinitely for
example if there weren't a current need
for but for some future build or
expansion of their Municipal radio
network and if so having that right of
first refusal would that require a City
County or state agency negotiate with
the town interoperability is also
another
consideration in a time where the need
for seamless Communications across many
different Radio Networks is critical to
Public Safety our Statewide
interoperability executive committee the
SI currently Works diligently to
identify solutions to create these
seamless Communications networks many of
which incorporate a number of
interoperable communication Solutions
which allow cross discipline and
multi-jurisdictional communication
conduits for emergency Communications
having flexibility to install these
Solutions both hardware and software
based on a greater scale could help
facilitate a larger multi-jurisdictional
a town a city a county or Statewide
response to a major incident having no
flexibility could restrict the public
saf the agency's ability to assist in a
response or delay First Responders
reaching the greatest segment of the
population for example a Tower located
in an adjacent town along its border to
a larger City May provide greater
coverage opportunities for that
City and their pop population as part of
either their coverage footprint or their
back haul designating only one agency is
having the initial priority could
potentially negatively impact efficient
response to Public Safety related calls
for service our other concern would be
that the commercial Tower company would
charge a premium for the uppermost
section of the Tower and in all
likelihood the highest in demand because
of the real estate and that if our first
responded organization wish to locate on
a new tower and would be restricted to
the uppermost section this may translate
into paying a premi premium market rate
C cing them commercial tenant revenue or
causing issues on the engineering design
side of the operation conversely Tower
owners could also charge Public Safety
commercial Market rates for the prime
spot since the bill doesn't reference
that the Spate is cost that space is
cost free and that occupancy would be at
a discounted rate in summary although
the intent of the bill I think is to
provide for greater emergency
communications for our first responder
Community which we're all in very much
favor of serious consideration of these
issues must be taken into account to
avoid any unintended
consequences I am am certainly available
for any questions any member of the
committee may have thank you for your
testimony questions representative McGee
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question Mr Doyle thank you
um my question is you know I think you
were here and understand the intent
maybe of the bill it is it do you think
it's possible for us to make changes to
this bill and take out some of the uh
directive language that's inappropriate
in order to help him solve the problem
he's trying to solve because I'm not
sure I understand how we would help him
do that thank you for the question I
think it's an awesome question I did
have a conversation with representative
PR uh about some of the concerns
relative to the bill and that's the
reason why the department of safety is
taking a neutral position and as I
mentioned to him earlier today we're
certainly in a position where we'd like
to have that discussion either initially
or ongoing in the event that this
something has some traction later on
down the road we want to make sure that
whatever it is that we're
doing as a
Statewide response whether that's the
town working with the county the county
working with the state the state working
with the town or local city there's
always a Communications component
associated with it and you can't just
say that the particular entity that has
the jurisdictional responsibility or or
or authority if you will based upon
what's written in the bill now to have
first wrer refusal on that Tower may not
be the most appropriate one there are
certain considerations but working with
the localities the counties which we're
doing a lot of right now as well um or
even other uh Statewide agencies which
we do on a regular basis makes the best
sense when we're trying to perform or Co
collaborate to bring to to table some of
Solutions do you need a
followup well I guess the followup would
be
uh maybe you don't no it was around the
original question which is solving his
problem right I'm not sure what he's
trying to solve by prescribing this type
of a solution
I and maybe I can answer that and I I
think I could put on my Public Safety um
manager's hat back in the day when I
worked as a local uh first responder um
in a town in miramac and there was
always a concern about being able to and
he mentioned gaps in coverage gaps in
radio coverage as most of you know it's
not a perfect world out there when it
comes to trying to provision help to
people who are in need of help when they
need it because those gaps exist because
of geographical anomalies with u the uh
the surface departer for the Earth or
they just don't have in this particular
case I think he mentioned the ability to
locate on Towers in and around areas
where those gaps currently exist
transmission for radio signal is
dependent upon a multitude of factors
and just having one Tower in one town
doesn't give a grant to have coverage at
infin item throughout that jurisdiction
so there have to be certain engineering
studies that have to go into play to
actually identify where those locations
would be best served a lot of tower
owners and landlords whether the
telecommunications companies or
otherwise will put up Towers based upon
demand of service whether it's a private
service or commercial service that's
needed and when they do that they may by
virtue of just locating in that
particular area offer a solution for a
public safety agency to collocate on
that Tower and fill that Gap that they
currently don't have and I think that's
where uh representative prw was was uh
illustrating when he mentioned the
issues out on the Sea Coast and the Sea
Coast is not alone with that there are a
lot of towns and a lot of municipalities
and counties around the state including
our state of New Hampshire that have
these gaps that exist and some are just
impossible to cover because the reach
isn't there because of the power of the
radios we don't have a geographic Tower
in a location that addresses it but our
first respond Community Works around
what those challenges are and there are
a lot of things that are happening now
and in the future that will address a
lot of those but I think what he's
trying to do is just say since these
telecommunications carriers or the tower
owners themselves are going to be
erecting some of these um facilities it
may behoove them to offer up space on
those locations to help facilitate radio
communications from a public safety
perspective representative Harrington
has a question thank you Mr chairman
just follow up what we just said that it
may be hoov them to do it is this a uh
potential problem that may exist in the
future or is it a real problem are the
telecommunication Tower owners are they
saying sorry we're not allowing you to
do this or is this just anticipation
that someone might say that in the
future I can't speak for representative
PR and what his his thoughts were when
putting this together I do know and for
years there have been a lot of um
collaborations amongst some of the
private Tower owners with local
municipalities to offer them space on
those towers as they uh construct them
we at the department of safety work very
closely with a number number of private
and state-owned and county-owned
entities that currently have facilities
Towers shelters in and around the state
we have leases with some we have
agreements with others that don't
incorporate an actual monetary exchange
of funds to have space on those Towers
it's all dependent upon the individual
Tower owner themselves and whether they
want to offer it up or not I don't know
if he's run into any roadblocks where a
tower owner has said no we're not going
to do it or if you want to you can pay
the market price which is what we offer
to anybody else that wants to get on
their Tower which can be up to a couple
hundred bucks a month up to several
thousands of dollars depending upon the
location and the demand for the service
or that location for that service in the
area thank
you Vice chair Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question I'll just I'll repeat what I
said earlier in the day um that I had
contacted my fire department in lary
who's told me that uh this bill
would make their negotiations easier uh
when they're trying to fill gaps and
then I heard from other Representatives
that live in rural areas that's that
that have said that it was more serious
than that that they have a lot of
serious gaps so my question
is understanding we're working with a
private entity on these towers what can
we do for them to not make negotiations
harder and to make it almost um their
priority to make sure that we have
public safety and Communications because
maybe it wasn't this true five or 10
years ago but certainly in the last
several months of this year uh the world
has proven that there are changes
happening and we need to be out in front
of communications and I think it's
incumbent upon all of us to put that
priority first so we can get
Communications out for the safety of our
people which is one of the primary
responsibil ities of
government thank you for your question
and I'll try to answer that by putting
on my what would I do if I were in their
shoes and not have to speak for them
because I think maybe they'd want to
speak for themselves but I think in
today's day and age where the focus has
been
on
lately a response to a major incident
whether that's a natural disaster
whether that's a man-caused incident
whether it's an AC of as salent or
otherwise Communications I mentioned
before is very high on the priority list
when it comes to coordinating a major
response and I think everybody
understands what some of those
challenges look like if I were a
telecommunications carrier or Tower
owner or I'm inclined to go ahead and
build or construct one I would want to
by virtue of my good nature and the
Goodwill that go along with it reach out
to my local public safety agencies or
the Statewide agencies responsible for
coordinating a major response and say
this is what I'm doing is this going to
be a help to you if I construct a tower
here in this location and what benefit
can I offer you to help facilitate a
Communications asset for a major
response in the event that one's needed
in that particular area that's what I
would
do
representative uh follow
up thank you uh real
quick what would you recommend there be
a mechanism to have to perhaps Foster
that
Goodwill there's always a thank you for
the question there's always a u the
analogy that there's a carrot and a
stick and I don't know if Force feeding
this is the way to go um my
understanding is and I think the
question was brought up earlier and I
don't have any anecdotal information to
say yay or nay that any first responder
agency or local municipality has been
told no you can't locate on our Tower
whether that was for just the offer or
whether that was for no cost I don't
know but I've not heard of any um of
anybody being told no out of the gate
um I don't know the answer to that
question and I don't want to sound like
I'm sidest stepping it because as I had
mentioned the tower owners the
telecommunication companies whoever it
is that's constructing these facilities
is in the business to make money and I
get it um but I think there's there's an
opportunity for them to actually show
their good nature when it comes to
facilitating a public safety agency
response or first responder response by
augmenting and partnering and
collaborating with another Public Safety
agency or a local agency to actually
facilitate emergency communications in
those
locations representative Bernardi who is
a co-sponsor has a question I'll allow
it because he's a
co-sponsor thank you Mr
chairman so I can testify to the reason
for this bill
and it deals with the fact that there
are
significant gaps in coverage in the Sea
Coast Area that's area I I come from um
and I I understand what you're saying
about the various uh potential legal
issues so my question is what is the
Department of Safety doing to understand
what these gaps are and to help the
local towns and communities deal with
them because right now in my towns I
don't see any input from Department of
Safety to address this hence the
Bill thank you for your question and I I
know our Statewide interoperability
coordinator and the Statewide
interoperability executive committee uh
have had conversations with some of the
emergency managers out on the Sea Coast
and we do know because of the terrain
out there and the lack of some of these
antennas and Towers it becomes a real
challenge to facilitate emergency
communications we don't have an answer
where we're able to actually as you can
imagine real estate is difficult to come
by everywhere nobody wants nobody wants
a radio communications Tower in their
backyard so it becomes even more
challenging so what is it that we can do
to help facilitate we've talked to and
we actually coordinate with many of our
Wireless Partners whether they're with
AT&T whether they're with Verizon
Wireless whether they're with T-Mobile
to help facilitate and we had heard a
little bit about Broadband discussion
earlier today facilitate augmenting land
mobile radio communications with a
Broadband solution and it could be any
number of things some of these radio
systems that are out there right now
actually have the ability to transmit
over land mobile radio and over the LTE
systems which are your cellular networks
at the same time Department of Safety
does not have those we do not use those
right now but those capabilities do
exist depending upon the radio
manufacturer and the vendor that the
individual town and municipality goes
with and there are a number of them now
that are out there that offer some of
these Solutions I would suggest that in
those types of locations that
engineering studies be done and you
consult with individuals who are experts
in that particular area to help
facilitate a conversation between the
Telecommunications carriers and the land
mobile radio vendor in those particular
towns or the county and or Rockingham
County has a huge footprint on in that
area to talk a little bit about what
some of those solutions would look like
and how they can better facilitate
emergency communications across that
wider
swath follow
up uh thank you so uh the the Broadband
problem is even worse there are bigger
holes in the Broadband than if you use
radio so um I understand your uh
recommendation to do engineering studies
but it's it's going to require more than
that it's going to and likely is going
and again thank you and I I appreciate
your comment because I agree it's going
to it's going to involve quite a few
different partners in any collaborative
effort to enhance emergency
communications regardless of where those
gaps are um and they don't just exist on
the Sea Coast I know anecdotally you
talked about them happening over on the
Sea Coast we have a lot of areas up in
the north country as well as out the
western part of the state that are still
underserved because of the lack of
broadband there's an initiative right
now to make sure that broad band is um
provisioned in areas that are under
repesentative it don't have that
capability and the ability to do that
provides another opportunity to help
augment emergency communications once
that expansion is
conducted further questions
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you uh for
being here and taking my question um in
the second paragraph of your testimony
you talk about um um the communities up
north uh that they can't this wouldn't
work for them being at the the top 20
feet of a tower because of the
FCC and so um you say that quote we've
settled at under 100 fet for those
locations my my question is is that 100
fet in law and the the second part of my
question is um if you're using 100 ft
under 100 ft up north could that be a
standard that's used throughout New
Hampshire thank you for your question
representative Thomas and I think the
there's a two-part answer there and
number one it's not set in law or
statute and I want to get back
to relegating as to where any type of
communications infrastructure should be
on a tower again because radio
communications is
not is not static it's Dynamic depending
upon a multitude of um factors
topography distance in which you're
going to try to cover whether it's a
microwave uh shot between two locations
whether it's a transmitter whether it's
a receiver antenna or otherwise so
depending upon I think the the question
is or the answer is it depends and it
depends upon what it is you're trying to
do whether you're trying to transmit to
a greater population whether you're
trying to receive a transmission from a
first responder to get it back home to
where it needs to go is all going to
depend upon where that antenna needs to
itself further
question thank you chair and thank you
for your testimony today um going back
to an earlier
question it's my understanding that do
Department of Safety is not the business
of erecting Towers so there's only so
much that you can actually do and we can
do through legislation but the tow but
where we have the real need are in
places where we're talking about the top
20 foot of a tower that doesn't
exist my understanding is please correct
me if I'm wrong this is the gist my
question um we're not building Towers in
those areas because the uh
telecommunications industry deems them
to be unprofitable so rather than that
they are focusing their efforts upon
metropolitan areas beefing up their 5G
and not really looking to develop the
more rural parts of our state where this
type of service especially for first
responder is so badly needed is that a
correct
characterization in in working with a
number of the um Wireless
telecommunications
carriers their focus from a uh business
perspective has to be where the need
exists and again they have to make money
uh the difference is that with the A&T
um supported first net program first net
is a system um designed by the federal
government I say designed by but the
board is actually um hosted by the
federal government to actually make sure
that First Responders have the ability
to use that um Public Safety Broadband
Network that's earmarked specifically
for our First Responders along the first
net uh platform and the first net
platform is being built in locations
that not only serve a commercial purpose
but will also serve a first responder
purpose but it's not an automatic either
um it's something that they work very
closely with our Statewide
interoperability executive committee to
actually design a plan we just actually
finish the first five your roll out of
the first net system here in New
Hampshire and they're actually uh
discussing and conversing right now to
find out what the next stage of that's
going to be for the next 5 years and
that might include that might include
construction of towers in locations that
would otherwise be overlooked because of
the lack of a commercial need but
there's a greater need for first
responder desire in those locations
because of lack of land mobile radio
coverage and you're right the department
of safety is not in the business of
building Towers unless we absolutely
need to as a matter of fact we only have
the department of safety owns only seven
Towers a Lo uh around the state and
locations around the state where we have
our radio equipment but we actually
collocate on about 49 different
locations around the state and some of
those are with some private enenes some
of those are with other state agencies
like Department of Natural and cultural
resources so we try to figure out where
it is that we need to have a footprint
and we try to build out upon that based
on existing
locations representative Ms has a
question thank you a quick one I hope
thank you thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question and I just
want to uh you know confirm what uh
representative Bernard Bernardi said
that there are you know very significant
holes on the Sea Coast I mean I live I
live in Hampton um and I also um want to
you know I think follow up on on a
comment that you made about you know the
fact that that we we we probably need to
have a more Regional or even Statewide
approach to solving some of these
problems because I know um I live in
Hampton and to improve cell phone
service in Hampton um we need a tower in
Northampton um just because of the
geography so with that in mind would it
you know if we were to proceed with this
bill would it make more sense to instead
of giving each individual Town and
County kind of first Di on Space to
instead say that um that space needs to
be allocated to you know the department
of safety so that the department of
safety can then perhaps through the
um through the Statewide interop
operability executive committee the
state could then determine that okay
there's a tower going up in Northampton
that will help the issue in in Hampton
and then there's a to Tower going in
Hampton that'll help the tower the
issues in Seabrook so that it becomes
more of a integrated solution as opposed
to a town Bytown solution thank you for
your question and I would suggest that
it wouldn't be the responsibility of the
Department of Safety to uh be that
deciding factor however what we've
always done and this is something that
we did since the beginning of the
establishment of the Statewide
interoperability executive committee is
invite local stakeholders whether the're
police Chiefs the fire chiefs the
Emergency Management directors to these
um meetings that we have quarterly to
have these conversations about what we
can do to help enhance radio coverage or
land mobile radio coverage or even
Broadband capabilities if they need back
haul associated with their radio network
and find solutions that may be existing
that they're not aware of that maybe the
department of s safety can help
facilitate whether it's having a local
meeting that would include Emergency
Management directors or Fire Chiefs or
police Chiefs from surrounding agencies
and jurisdictions to come to the table
to discuss with whoever the landlord
landl landlord or owner of the tower is
to facilitate that conversation I think
it's something that we could certainly
do representative n rolds has a
question thank you Mr chairman um I want
to my question gonna hearken back to
something that you said earlier just uh
I think kind of quickly in your in your
testimony um as a policy maker I
always want to try to get to the root of
a problem I see this bill uh as an
attempt that you know to address a
problem but I'm not sure that it's it's
aiming in the right direction uh I think
we've all heard the the saying you know
some wag in the past once said we have
met the enemy
and he is US isn't the isn't the root of
the problem of large gaps in uh cellular
coverage and thus radio coverage or the
lack of towers in certain certain places
isn't the root of that problem local
opposition to building such Towers I you
you made reference I think you said your
words are exactly no one wants to look
at a tower so is the issue that private
companies who manage to build a tower
aren't giving
municipalities uh space you know Public
Safety uh agencies space on those Towers
or is is it that
private companies want to build towers
but they can't because local towns and I
won't name any on the Sea Coast but um I
I'm neighbor to some won't let Towers
get
built thank you for your question and I
I don't have an answer to that because
I'm not involved in a lot of that
discussion at the local level um other
than you hear and I say hear anecdotally
from some of the discussion with some of
our Emergency Management directors that
it's difficult um to get those approvals
and I don't know what that means
necessarily other than again what I've
heard is that it becomes difficult
because as you can imagine the confined
nature of both the population and the
commercial districts over on the Sea
Coast I I think it becomes a challenge
to try to get a tower in any of those
locations that folks might consider um
is a a barrier to the scenic beauty of
the Sea Coast and that becomes a
challenge I don't have an answer for
that uh but there are solutions that are
available that may not necessarily
necessitate the construction of a tower
there are small cells or fto cells and
some other things that are available
that certainly don't have the far reach
that a cell tower does but can provide
some very localized access to Cellular
Communications but may not help the
radio communications piece so I guess
the answer is I don't
know okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank Mr Doyle for his uh
testimony here this morning and call on
the last speaker on House Bill 1078 and
that's representative Deb Hobson from
East
chair thank you representative and uh
I'd ask you to be brief as we have one
more public hearing to get to before our
lunch break I will be super brief thank
thank you so much members of the
committee my name is Deb Hobson I'm
representative out of Rockingham
district 14 I didn't even know that I
was going to speak today I had several
other bills so uh it's by the luck of
the draw that I'm here I wanted to um
speak in support of this measure um as a
a representative that meets with my uh
East Kingston Fire Department and other
area towns um we know that something has
to happen to increase communication uh
for about 4 years years we've been
meeting with members of the First
Responders and um some of the things
that have come into play with this um
situation obviously the topography um
has been an issue we've got very hilly
terrain um the um I guess inconsistence
inconsistencies between digital and
analog um the First Responders are
having to carry around multiple radios
so that they can uh get all the
information they need about a particular
service call um loud noises will cause
digital to go out and our um fire chief
in East Kingston has um talked about uh
the security of his First Responders not
knowing what kind of a situation he's
they're going to
enter
um just wanted to point those things out
this seemed to be a um lowcost
reasonable solution and we do have have
issues in the towns that
um people will vote down cell towers but
I do think that we have several towers
that are going up and um I think that
this is happening uh cell towers are uh
having repeaters placed on the top uh
portions of cell towers in certain areas
of the state so we thought that this
would be a good measure um so you know
certainly some good things have been uh
brought up in this hearing and I would
just ask that um we not put this off any
longer I know we have a state
interoperability uh task force but um I
think that our First Responders need a
little bit more fast action so that's
that's all I have thank you thank you
representative Hopson any questions for
the
representative representative
Harrington thank you Mr chairman um one
issue that was brought up briefly earli
it hasn't been touched on much in all
this discussion is the legality of doing
this we're talking about private
property that's owned by private
companies and we're saying we're going
to apparently this law would force them
to give access to government uh is that
even legal to do that has anyone looked
into that part of it because I haven't
heard it addressed at all you know I
don't have an answer thank you for the
question I don't have an answer for that
um yeah I I don't thank
you
okay seeing no further questions for the
representative I'm going to close the
public hearing
on House Bill
1078 and representative Thomas will now
while representative o is preparing to
testify I would remind uh uh our
committee members that um the only that
stands between representative OES your
and your questions is lunch and so um
make your questions brief and I think
this is a relatively simple bill so
representative o explain what you are
doing thank you actually it's questions
that stand between the members and lunch
not me
the house bill
1627 is the result of
a bill that we passed last year House
Bill
219 which set up a study committee to
determine whether or not certain
statutes that were codified under title
34 titled Public Utilities should be
moved to Title 20
Transportation most of these statutes re
relate to Railroad activities which the
Public Utilities Commission did at one
time regulate but stopped
regulating those particular activities
back in the 1920s or
1930s so all this bill does so the
result of that study committee was we
looked at these statutes and said yes
they should be moved from Public
Utilities to Transportation or in one
case Department of Safety
and so what this bill does is it does or
authorizes uh those chapter transfers so
if you look at lines 1 through three of
the bill it says chapter transferred
Transportation RSA 367 on the formation
and Union of railroad corporations
leases extensions is hereby transferred
to Title 20 and shall be red as RSA 243
consisting of 23 2431 through
24357 and it just goes on like that
throughout the text of the entire Bill
transferring one bill to
another
and lines if you go to page two lines 20
through the end of that page and the
lines all the lines on page three are
just Corrections that are
required by the removal
of these chapters from one title to
another so it's strictly a housekeeping
bill that
puts statutory language where it should
go in the proper title under our
statutes and I have a letter that was
sent to me yesterday by the Public
Utilities Commission that
says re hb1 1627 dear chairman Vose Vice
chairman Thomas and members of the
committee the commission is writing to
express its support of hb1 1627 this
bill would recodified statutes currently
found under RSA title 34 entitled Public
public utilities which no longer relate
to the regulation of Public Public
Utilities the commission defer ref to
the committee and relevant State
agencies regarding how these statutes
should be recodified
it thanks Chairman's Vos for sponsoring
this legislation signed by Daniel
goldner and Carlton
Simpson so I'm not sure if M maybe all
members of the committee received that
letter maybe they did but I just wanted
to read that into the record um just in
case and with that I'd be happy to take
any questions or one more quick thing
representative uh Corman served on the
study committee with myself and
representative Greg Hill there were two
other members of the committee a senator
I believe it was Senator alt schilter
schilter and um another representative
whose name I don't remember they never
actually attended any of our committee
sessions but um representative and
Corman and I did the work on this and
we're satisfied that this bill satisfies
the study committee's
requirements thank you representative o
I see uh representative bernardy not
question thank you Mr Vice chair uh any
any uh disagreement from the Department
of Transportation or Department of
Safety in taking these new assignments
or reassigning them to them no the study
committee spoke to representatives from
both the Department of Transportation
and the department of safety and they
were in agreement that these statues
should be moved and were supportive of
the
effort representative Winnie
Thomas thank you very much um you had
just no no opposition to this bill this
is a as you said it's just cleaning up
but you had mentioned that one case was
referred to the Department of Safety is
that what starts on line one on page two
and goes
to 16 is that is that what you're
talking about the one case that goes to
Safety actually it goes from line one to
line two
yes lines three and Beyond are uh
corrected reference
and necessitated by the move in lines
one and two 14 and
15 yes that's another TR chapter that's
been transferred yes okay all right just
wanted to understand thank
you representative Ms thank you Mr
chairman and thank thank you uh Mr
chairman um I I I am very hungry but my
sense of public duty is uh overriding my
stomach right now um just a quick
question on um page
two um line 18 it talks about inserting
the following new
subdivision is that language new or is
that moving something from somewhere
else that's moving something from
somewhere else which was one of the
report followup followup so why why is
subdivision I don't have the study
committee report right in front of me
representative Corman do you remember
what the circumstances
were it's in the study committee report
I would refer you to that report uh to
get an answer to your question actually
I can I can Venture a guess
and that is uh the other parts of this
bill are renumbering rsas entirely this
one is actually just about a
section and I I think with sections we
have to move them a section at a time my
question is is it a new program or not
it's an existing program that's just
being yeah it's just moving the text
it's an existing piece of Statute that's
just being
moved seeing no question questions and
seeing having no other speakers here
thank you m uh representative o and I
declare this public hearing
closed and I further declare that our
session is adjourned for lunch until
then
it's 1:30 and I would like to now open a
public hearing on House Bill
dfn a bill prohibiting the intentional
release of polluting emissions including
cloud seating weather
modification excessive electromagnetic
radio frequency and microwave radiation
and making penalties for violation of
such prohibition and I would like to
introduce the sponsor of the bill
representative geard to introduce this
legislation good afternoon and welcome
to
St good
afternoon thank you members of the
today let me just first say this I have
never received so much positive feedback
from a bill that I've put in this is
It's been insane I've had people contact
me from all over the country uh South
Dakota sen got in touch with me among
other people it's been really really
impressive so I want to thank everybody
that came today first off and just the
support I've had for this but this bill
comes about because of quite frankly
pollution being instituted implemented
in our atmosphere from the government
under the aices of countering global
warming and increasing rainfall snow and
and a number of other things that people
much smer than myself will talk about
after I step down but I want to bring up
quite quickly that Mexico a year ago
banned geoengineering in 2010 there was
an international ban 190 countries I
believe signed on to that yes and then
Mexico last year did it again in
reinstituted because of a company make
sunsets
Incorporated changing the color of of a
Sunset and they weren't happy about it
so from their statement I just want to
words and of course I don't have that up
right
now the government of Mexico reiterates
its unavoidable commitment to the
protection and well-being of the
population against practices that
generate risks to human and
environmental security working in a
coordinated rigorous and responsible
manner for the well being of the people
of
Mexico and I think that's pretty pretty
impressive because there's a lot of
things that happen in Mexico that don't
happen in the United States and the fact
that they're regulating geoengineering
more so than the United States is is
something that we need to take a look at
and especially in light of the damage
that has occurred from excessive
flooding and other catastrophes that
have affected New Hampshire particular
and I just find so I don't know if this
is actually going to go forward but I
know through the Great Vine there was
talk
of uh providing a relief fund for
Farmers that have been affected this
year and I don't know exactly the status
that is but the idea that the taxpayers
in New Hampshire are going to subsidize
destruction from the federal government
through the weather manipulation is
just it's absurd so that's why I brought
the bill
forward it's it's pretty wide ranging as
you can tell and I don't even want to
get too deep into into it but the basic
point being the idea of trying to drop
chemicals to stop global warming just
doesn't make any sense we need to just
step away let the environment do do what
it needs to do and then figure out if
there's any need for man-made
manipulation of the weather so hopefully
that makes some sense and if it doesn't
there's a whole bunch of people behind
me that'll give more in detailed
information I'll take questions if I can
answer them if not I'm sure you'll find
questions before the day is
out okay thank you for answers
introducing this legislation questions
from the committee representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Gard for taking my
question um I imagine that you've read
the bill as is and that there's a fiscal
note on the bill uh the Department of
Environmental Services uh states that
it's actually going to have quite a big
fiscal impact on that department I'm
wondering if you could comment on
that
oh you will okay well then I'll let
represent penzo do uh take care of that
in
detail further questions from the
committee representative
Harrington yeah thank you Mr chairman
than be Tak my question on uh page one
on getting down okay on line 21 it says
talks about regulation by the state and
it talks about all state CLA climate
related appointees must be or have been
administered the
state oath of office and should fulfill
the obligations there under to protect
state and federal constitutions what
exactly does that mean what's a what's a
State climate related appoin ises that
Define someplace and what oath that
they're not taking would this require
them to take I believe this was
instituted to prohibit state employees
from basically working hand inand with
the federal government without letting
us because right now on the books
they're supposed to notify the people of
New Hampshire when such geoengineering
happens it hasn't happened there's been
no notification and there's kind of a
game where they they play the game of
See No Evil Hear No Evil they weren't
notified so they don't have to notify us
and I think what this is attempting to
get at is putting them under well the
oath of fulfilling their duty to protect
us from what the federal government's
doing I mean I could be wrong if I'm
wrong then I'm
that's how I look at it but I
followup followup okay you mentioned
state employees but this talks about
appointees so it wouldn't be state
employees I assume this is someone with
appointees meaning it was appointed by
the governor confirmed by the executive
counsel and they the ministered the oath
of office I mean I was appointed and I
had an oath of office it was it's done
for everybody I'm not sure what this
what is this doing that's different I
is I just thought it was put everybody
on a Level Playing Field that everybody
has take an out to defend the people of
New Hampshire and their rights and the
environment and so forth that's what I
was representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for coming today I
have a question on um is line 14 in in
the text it says uh I'll just read it
due to necessity arising from federal
stance and the potential needs for
enemies for foreign and domestic to
cause harm intentionally and it goes on
so I was I was just curious are these
enemies the foreign and domestic are
they the enemies of the federal
government or are they enemies of the
state and is there a list somewhere that
would define those the similar question
is is this defined in statute anywhere
or who who is going to determine who who
these people are I would say anybody
that's altering our environment without
the people's permission I mean or the or
the people's knowledge of what they're
doing the idea of spraying a chemical
into the air under the offices of making
the the environment better it's just
it's absurd I mean just I don't know how
else to put it so I I don't know if that
but representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Gard for taking my
question um I had a bunch of stuff
highlighted here but I wanted to talk a
little bit about sort of the nuts and
bolts of some of the points you have in
here on page two sure let me put my
glasses
on um you you list that the commissioner
of the Department of Environmental
Services will immediately issue a cease
and desist order upon the discovery of
stratospheric aerosol injections cloud
seeding weather modification or other
atmospheric polluting activity including
excessive electromagnet magnetic radio
frequency microwave radiation emissions
where an agency Department office
program or member of the public uh um
produces evidence to the department or
to New Hampshire County Sheriffs that
the activity may be harmful or involves
the releasing of polluting emissions my
question is I did a little research into
sort of how cloud seating or that type
of thing has has happened in the United
States so far and it's been the states
that have been requesting it because
they've been you know had lower amounts
of rain or whatever so the so the wasn't
the federal government imposing you know
seating and this is saying that we're
going to have um agency heads and local
sheriffs be the people who will try and
enforce this but how will they know
who's seating if it's something that's
happening that we're not already
informed of I'm just trying to figure
out how the bill would work indeed I
would there's a delineation between
cloud seating and then the solar
radiation management nonsense stuff
they're putting into thegu to block the
Sun
so I think can I ask who is they though
because you keep saying they and I who
who is doing it is anyone doing it here
federal
government if the state was doing it
then they're in violation of even more
laws because they're supposed to be
notifying us of as um representative
Aaron's previous bill that was passed
21 That was supposed to notify the
people of New Hampshire when this was
occurring we've never been notified so
as far as State's concerned it isn't
happening but we all know it's happening
hence the turnout which is pretty
day additional questions representative
PL has a question uh thank you chair and
thank you for taking my question working
off representative McGee's question is
there any states that have looking into
this similar type of legislation or has
it yes Rhode
Island unfortunately my notes are a bit
messy
yes representative poza has the list
among other states R Island's
introducing legislation right now
Tennessee I believe there's a couple
others as well Iowa and well trust me
there's plenty of people here who have
been studying this up to theth degree
it's pretty impressive actually
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair um so I liken I mean
nobody nobody is supports U pollution of
any kind of course
um and I Come From the Past pollution
world of marac so I see a I see some
similarities here on lines seven and
eight on page one you talk about that it
harms human health and the safety um the
environment agriculture Wildlife
Aviation State security and the economy
of the State of New
Hampshire one of the problems we've had
with p is proof of damage MH so um and
we've it's taken us seven years for to
get proof of damage what are you relying
on what statistics reports or studies
are you relying on to prove all of these
things are harmed for the actual in
detailed statistics we're going to leave
that to represent poten of but there's
been studies on the snow pack and
actually finding excessive amounts of
aluminum barium barium stron stonum okay
I'm not so there's there's actually
plenty of evidence believe or not
unfortunately it's just taking so long
to get this off the ground because most
people just dismiss it as craziness even
though you can see it test for it so I
know that's not exactly answering your
question but trust me before this this
hearing is over you will be fully
satisfied I guarantee that I'm
out representative parshall has a
question thank you chair thank you for
being here today you just mentioned
Barum barium was uh claimed in the 1990s
to be included with Chemtrails in order
to pacify our citizens uh it's a claim
that I don't think is withstood uh any
scientifically researched peer
peer-reviewed
research however there is a lot of
research on such things as uh CO2
emissions and uh the effect of that on
our environment such as what's going on
in Hampton
Beach um
now while I am very concerned
about the emissions that come from jet
fuel I really find a lack of evidence
towards all these allegations against
things such as barium do you have any
scientific research that you can point
to
and me personally no but my team yes we
have plenty of evidence but getting back
to the jet fuel it's not the jet fuel
this is not part of the concern at all
it's the intentional spraying of
chemicals while these airplanes are
flying there's patents showing the
actual spraying apparatus this is not
just byproducts of the um burning of
fuel normal airplanes don't
leave yes we'll we'll get to that and I
will get back to you on the barium if
somebody else doesn't answer that before
the day is
out representative Ms has a question uh
thank thank you Mr chair thank thank you
for taking my question I I actually have
it's it's like a two-part question that
kind of talks follows on representative
McGee's comment about you know the nuts
and bolts of how this works sure um the
the the the the first question is um I I
found it interesting that the Bill calls
out New Hampshire County Sheriffs as uh
one of the entities to report these
violations to and it was unclear as to
why that wasn't um why the county
sheriff's why not the New Hampshire
Department of Safety
the county sheriffs are the highest law
enforcement officer in the county
they're directly responsible to the
people obviously I mean that comes from
the old English and so forth but the
point being is they actually have a
higher standing in the scheme of
protecting the people than all these
appointed entities that's why I chose
the county sheriffs
followup
followup and then I I guess the other
question I had was um you know it talks
about uh if if anyone
um detects any of these um pollutants
they they have an obligation to report
them but you know is there a is there a
standard that they need to follow I mean
is the you know is and how do you me how
you know how do we measure it you you
know if you if you find one part per
billion is that enough to report or is
there going to be a higher standard you
know just can you shed some light on
that
my my position would be to identify the
aircraft then with flight trackers you
can figure out who owns the plane and
then at that point wait till it lands
and you can do testing at that point or
we can do other testing it's just
obviously if there's a plane thousands
of feet up how you going to say that
even if you had a ground base test how
you going to sa it's from that plane I
understand the complications but at the
same time if these planes are doing this
on the regular basis I don't think it
would be that difficult to track said
plane and wait till it lands or if need
be force it to land
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
again just following up on on that
answer um a plane flying over New
Hampshire is not necessarily Landing in
New Hampshire so how are you going to
enforce checking on that
plane plane flying over New Hampshire is
VI is in our airspace and can be forced
Hampshire yes follow up I mean just and
and and what New Hampshire entity is
going to force that plane to land we'll
have to find out which one would be the
most responsible I'm I'm assuming we
chose representative McGee has a
question I I have a followup I'm just
listening listening to everything um I
actually I have a copy of the uh
coverage of the prior bill that was
passed saying that the measure requires
that public input before experiments can
be conducted and so my question goes to
you're asserting that this is happening
right that you believe that this is
happening yes and yet we have a law that
says it can't happen without letting us
know yes and so um I I I guess the
question would be and I know you're
going to say the people behind me but uh
how we have evidence of this because my
understanding is that the atmosphere is
governed by the Environmental Protection
agency and they have a Clean Air Act
standard which has been updated like 28
times since it was first put in place in
1955 it doesn't include these types of
pollutants at this point so that might
be an appropriate place for some updates
now but but what I uh as I was trying to
kind of research the issue it appears
that the federal government only
authorizes state governments to
undertake this type of proceeding if and
when they feel they are in some kind of
danger of not having the rainfall or the
snowfall that actually supports their
economy so the decisions around whether
someone is allowed to do this
um appear to be made by the states and
so I'm just I'm just trying to figure
out how you know something that none of
those other entities that are involved
in it
know I'm just trying to pull up the
specific answer to your question which I
actually
have so anyway
states banned said spraying but then in
1976 a law was passed by Congress to
allow it at the federal level so what
happened was basically they superseded
the state's ability to regulate it until
at this point which I think we should
reassert our state sovereignty and say
no we're done with that the point being
is the cloud seeding I believe is two
the two different topics going on so the
geoengineering is kind of let's think
I'm just now obviously I'm probably
gonna be told that I'm wrong but it's
the blocking of the Sun and other
aspects of it but the cloud seating is
simply increasing rainfall or snow or
whatever it may be so the the federal
government basically said this larger
overarching mission is our primary
responsibility and as far as cloud
seating goes the state still because I I
want to say it was out in Colorado I
just reading about this last night they
ended up stopping cloud seeding at one
of the resorts just because the cost was
too high so I mean this is still on
going all over the place it's obviously
when money gets tight they cut back on
certain things but so I probably didn't
answer your question but I'm hoping that
someone behind me will fully answer that
for you or represent poeno would
probably be better for that thank you
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair um on page three on
lines 113 15 and 21 you reference the
Department of Environmental Services M
however on line eight you reference the
Department of Environmental air
Resources Division of
compliance can you tell me
uh why you called out that uh line eight
I think it's a typo yeah I'm not exactly
I don't know how to answer that only
because I know they do specific uh I'm
going to just avoid that because I don't
want to answer the wrong way you think
that's a typo yes because the Department
of Environmental Services does have an
air
resources no I understand that but why
my my question is why does he reference
on on line one the Department of
Environmental Services line 13 the
Department of Environmental Services
line 15 and 21 same thing and yet online
8 he references the Department of
Environmental air Resources Division of
compliance so why is that specific
agency called out separate from the
other ones my guess is that the air
Resources Division is where you would
register your uh that's where the
evidence will be submitted right
directly to them they're the ones that
actually do fine particulate matter
analysis I contacted them before putting
the bill in and they basically said they
are not testing for the certain
chemicals that I asked so we have
somebody from Dees who will be testified
you okay seeing no further questions we
want to thank you representative for
introducing this legislation and next
I'll call on representative Kelly
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
for hearing my
testimony so I'm I'm speaking on this
specifically on the um underneath
especially with being uh a member of
environment and agriculture on pollution
so the toxicity of geoengineering
geoengineering agents is well documented
in scientific literature so there might
be many people that are on this
committee that are not familiar with it
um there's many people that are New
Hampshire citizens that have no idea
what is happening what is happening not
just in the state but AC but literally
uh across the country and the entire
planet so geoengineering is the
intentional manipulation of course of
the weather it's changing the Earth's
atmosphere and ining the environment Geo
engineering has been going on for
decades and I have found early documents
that date back a century on this the New
Hampshire citizens never gave consent to
manipulated man-made weather occurrences
part one article one all men are born
equally free and independent therefore
all government of right originates from
the people and is founded in in consent
and instituted for the general good this
is not for the general
good uh part one article 8 all power
residing origin in and being derived
from the people all magistrates and
officers of the government are
substitutes and agents and all times
accountable to them government therefore
should be open accessible accountable
and responsive to that end the Public's
right to of access to governmental
proceedings and Records shall not be
unreasonably
restricted and then Part
12 nor the inhabitant of the state
controllable by any other laws than
those to which they or their
representative body have given
consent such Reckless interventions and
injury are in our infringement on our
rights and our extremely damaging to our
life in Liberty in New Hampshire on this
planet that's part one article one so
founded in consent instituted for the
general good so I want you to please
support this effort to one protect our
environment natural resource versus
wildlife and most importantly the health
safety and well-being of the people of
New Hampshire the protection of the
environment and
concerns um and concerns public health
and safety must be of the highest
priority not the agency that is supposed
to be monitoring this stating we have no
knowledge of this occurring in New
Hampshire I put the packet that had
Title One um chapter 12f the weather
modification experimentation on E on in
front of each of you and I'll get back
to
that like I said we have no knowledge of
this occurring in New Hampshire we all
need to work together to pass the clean
atmosphere preservation act this is not
a political matter it's a people matter
we must do more than prevent pollution
especially which it's intentional
pollution regulations are essential to
protect and preserve everyone's right to
breathe clean air to breathe clean
healthy air and prohibit harmful
pollution deployments of geoengineering
contaminants including cloud-seeding
aerosols and radio frequency microwave
rfmw radio emissions subject our state
and planet to highly unnatural hazards
we the people do not consent to these
animals so the argument to stop the
releasing of man-made aerosols such as
sulfur dioxide sulfuric acid uh which is
h2so4 graphine oxide and aluminum oxide
and there's several others but those are
what I'm going to cover today is
grounded in various factual
environmental health and ethical
concerns here are the key points
supporting the termination of releasing
these man-made aerosols one
environmental air PCT air water air and
water pollution so sulfur dioxide
sulfuric a acid graphine oxide aluminum
oxide all contribute to air and water
pollution harming ecos systems soil and
Aquatic Life acid reain formation sulfur
dioxide and sulfuric acid emissions
contribute to acid rain formation which
have detrimental effects on soil quality
vegetation and Aquatic e ecosystems
human health respiratory and
cardiovascular issues sulfur dioxide and
sulfuric acid can lean to respiratory
and cardiovascular problems in humans
when inhaled inhalation of fine
particles like graphine oxide and
aluminum oxide also pose health risks
and then the potential toxicity the full
scale of health health effects of
graphine oxide are not yet fully
understood but its toxicity has already
been established and of course climate
change contributing to uh global warming
so certain aerosols including sulfur
dioxide can contribute to the global
warming effect by reflecting sunlight
back into space while this also has a
cooling effect it does not address the
root cause of climate change and has of
course unintended consequences ethical
considerations Public Safety and Health
governments have an ethical
responsibility to prioritize public
health and safety releasing aerosols
with health and environmental risks and
consequences are considered a breach of
their fiduciary responsibilities and
then the most important thing I'd have
to say and the ethical is informed
consent there are ethical concerns about
the releases of substances like graphine
Oxide without fully understanding and
everything else that I've mentioned
their potential impacts informed consent
of the public is crucial and matters
that could affect health and
well-being long-term side effects we
have no idea what these could um what
could equate to for our of course not
just our New Hampshire citizens but our
entire country and the planet so there
are alternatives and sustainable
practices that can be used to promote
cleaner Technologies of course um with
what they are trying to do in regards
with their geoengineering that has not
even been looked at um investment in
Green Solutions um the government can
invest in research and development
certain alterio Sol um alternative
solutions that do not pose significant
environmental heal rks and then there's
that red you know the Regulatory
Compliance so we have to adhere to
environmental regulations and right now
it's uh it's basically like the Wild
Wild West out there there's none of them
and if
a lot of you guys want um data I will
provide you with links to everything
that's right on uh right on DC right
from the White House's um their own
studies and everything all the way up
until 2024 I will give you everything
that you need it's right there at your
taking this is not hidden it's right in
front of our it's right in front of our
eyes so the government of course is
fully responsible for acting ethically
by considering the potential risks and
consequences of these substances so I
just want to
speak try to go quickly let's just talk
about sulfur dioxide and sulfuric acid
okay so we already know it's a
respiratory irritant so SO2 is a known
respiratory irritant exposure to high
concentrations can cause resp
respiratory problems in humans acid
formation the release of so SO2
contributes to acid formation which have
of course detrimental effects on
ecosystems so I don't know if everybody
knows this but if we just go to dhh yes
so right now New Hampshire has some of
the highest rates of asthma across the
country with with between 2014 in 2016
the CDC estimates putting it as putting
it as the state with the highest adult
asthma pre prevalence asthma affects
13.2% of New Hampshire adults 7.2 7.21%
of New Hampshire children accounting for
over 4,000 emergency room visits and
over 177 million in direct medical costs
graphine oxide this is taken from a
study the band gap of graphine oxide can
be easily tuned and therefore it has a a
wide range of photocatalyic applications
as well uh the degradation of organic
canins uh contaminants excuse me um
hydrogen generation CO2 reduction Geo
could be a potential nanocarrier and
Drug Delivery Systems Gene delivery
biological sensing in antibacteria nanoc
composits due to its large surface area
and high high density um as it is highly
functional with oxygen containing
functional groups well let's get to the
the meat and bat the meat and potatoes
it has been observed that the super
oxide dismutase sod and reactive oxygen
species R levels gradually increase over
a period after gra graphine oxide is
introduced into the biological systems
hence specific concentrations are toxic
for species like earthworms for our
Agriculture and making our our our crops
grow as well as for Aquatics zebra fish
Etc aluminum
oxide this is the big one so inhalation
of fine aluminum oxide particles May
pose health risks particularly to the
respiratory system I talked about asthma
before so a possible geoengineering
method to mitigate the global warming
aspect of climate change is the
injection of aerosols into the lowest
Stratosphere close closely Mimi in the
way a large volcanic eruptions cool the
climate the method is called solar
radiation manage management SRM scheme
or simply solar gen geoengineering so s
SRM has been suggested to be affordable
and have high Effectiveness compared
with other like geoengineering schemes
that have been suggested to mitigate
global warming so while sulfate aerosols
are the most studied it has been
recently shown that aerosols with other
compositions aluminum oxide alumina
Diamond could be used to dramatically
increase the amount of light scatter
achieved on a per Mass basis aluminum
particles found after the alumni aerosol
injection are more efficient scatterers
and may have less severe techn
technology specific risks than
sulfates thus they're expected to be
more efficient per unit mass for
geoengine applications we conclude that
there's strong evidence that aluminum
can cause irritation following exposure
via inhalation or injection modest
evidence of effects for Reproductive
toxicity following oral exposure for
neurological um toxicity following
either oral or injection exposure and
for bone toxicity following injection
exposure all other effects um all other
effects were judged to be supported by
either limited evidence or no clear
evidence at all exposure assessment dose
response assessment risk
characterization were conducted for
those those effects which evidence was
judged to be either strong or modest the
remainder of the section describes our
findings for the general population at
special risk um occupationally exposed
population aluminum has also been
regarded as um posing a health hazard if
um specifically when we're talking about
dementia and in Alzheimer's I have some
hand outes if you'd like so the
condition is most common form of
dementia it may contribute to 60 70% of
the cases of course of Alzheimer in 2015
dementia affected 47 million people
worldwide or roughly 5% of the world's
elderly population a figure predicted to
increase to 75 million in 2030 and 132
Million by 2050 recent reviews estimate
that each near each year nearly 9.9
million people develop dementia globally
this figure translates into one new case
every 3 seconds so even prolonged
exposure to low levels of aluminum leads
to changes associated with brain aging
and neurod
degeneration and as you know it's all
about the load so how long you're
experien to that how many it it's just
for for example for sickness I interrupt
you for just a second you requested 10
minutes from now going on 15 okay and
you're wandering away from the subject
of the bill so I'd like you to wrap it
up if you could please okay but this is
the subject of the bill because this is
what is in um this is what is in these
planes so I gave you uh first a copy of
what the current weather modification
experimentation is I gave you just a
little handout um this here is the
platform NOAA twin otter payload that is
exactly what the the aircraft looks like
that is filled with these chemicals and
it tells you um it has all of the um it
has it tells you exactly what gets
loaded in there so
um and then I also just so you could
have a little bit of History because the
the document that is from the White
House that they just put out is um is a
huge document it's I think it's over 70
pages so I wasn't going to do that on my
printer at home and do 20 copies but
this was from agriculture defense
Coalition press release so this was in
2010 and this shows you what um what
they were spraying in the in the um
through their
SRM and what was happening then NASA
research you know studies show that
increasingly persistent jet contrails
may turn into manmade clouds D trapping
warmth in the atmosphere there's a whole
slew of things here that talk about this
and a and a lot and I have tons and tons
of links that I can give you
um the other piece that I wanted to talk
about real quick and then I'll I'll wrap
up is so the current 12f document let's
be clear here under one any department
or agency of the state may with the
approval of the government and Council
and within limits of appropriated funds
or by means of gifts donations or grants
engage in undertake experimentation in
the techniques and methods for weather
modification and may cooperate therein
with the Federal ederal government with
authorized agencies of other states and
with interested persons and
organizations so now if we go to at
least two months prior to the
presentation approval of Engagement or
experimentation in techniques and
methods for weather modification the
department or agency of the state
participating in such engagement or
experimentation shall do the following
place a public notice and all of that
the federal government is included in
this and just to speak to the question
in regards with
um the cost of this or there shouldn't
have to be any cost this would be a
request so for example this committee
could um could put in a uh request or in
a sense a legislative uh you know uh
demand to get for the last three years
since 2021 how many uh Federal planes
how much geoengineering has taken place
in New Hampshire I think that's where we
start to see exact L what has what has
gone on now that should have happened
from Dees that's a simple ask that
doesn't need a a new salary a new
position or anything like that it's
about what for us to know what is going
on I'm I'm in Rochester I'm very close
to peas Air Force Base I can tell you
that I have a neighbor across the street
uh she's 80 years old she she has never
seen this kind of weather that we've had
um ever and and in planes flying and
Cloud patterns and all of that kind of
stuff and uh and she actually um she's a
graduate of unh and um and is very very
inen with the environment so listening
to people and this is a huge thing I've
had the same thing contact from all over
legislators from um other states I've
talked to people in New Jersey
Pennsylvania Florida uh Colorado New
Mexico so this is a huge issue and uh we
need to know what's going on here and
Hampshire thank you questions from the
committee representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for coming in and
presenting your bill you know I I also
have a lot of concerns about the
environment I agree the weather is is
changing the climate is changing and and
we know what the causes of that are it's
not contrails and the planes uh so you
know there's climate change um
I'm I'm concerned with some of the
effects of the pollutants that you
mentioned aluminum lead in the air all
these things have tremendous detrimental
effects on on on us on on on the public
and we ought to be doing something about
it with this bill you you claim that you
you know that this is happening yet you
say you want to find out what's going on
I agree I would like to find out what's
going on if this is happening I I think
we need to find out but I'm not sure
it's happening and I'm not sure you're
sure either so I think really what you
want to do is have maybe a study
commission where the state requests this
information and puts together some some
of the data that is lacking and and we
go from there but this this none of that
is in this bill so my question to you is
why haven't you formed a study
commission before coming forward with
this
bill well I jumped on this bill as a
co-sponsor I know it's an issue I do
know that it's happening I'm not talking
about contrails I'm talking about
man-made geoengineering that has been
going on for decades to in like
literally a century so I'll provide
every single document that will come
from the federal government that will
prove to you that they are doing it they
tell you that they're doing it that
there's no secret here so it's that
that's to me I didn't even feel like I
had to be on this committee and argue
that that's a given it's happening there
there's Partnerships right now with
United Nations in doing it it it's
happening so um but if that me a study
committee is is fantastic but I also
want to make sure um I want to know what
has been happening in New Hampshire
since 2021 when reporting was supposed
to be done if that if that a study
committee will help with that wonderful
but there was a study committee that
took place with had everything to do
with my committee with cob bacteria and
I think the state spent
$30,000 and we've done nothing with that
and our Lakes continue to be uh poison
by fertilizer phosphorus and some other
entities that people don't realize are
running off into the Lakes so this is
a this is one of the biggest issues that
we're facing right now and um there's a
I would I'm going to provides tons of
information for you the folks over in
California in regards with wildfires and
stuff like that um that that are
happening that that are that we know are
happening from some of these things that
are taking place um
I'll I'll get every bit of testimony
every bit of of reports that you need
from the federal government that will
tell you what is happening but I for
specifically to New Hampshire I think we
have to I think we have to find out and
if a study committee is where we go then
great representative licki has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question representative uh
I just looked up you mentioned graphine
oxides I just looked up graphine and
according to what I saw it says it's
just a form of carbon why would the
oxide of graphine be any different from
the oxide of anything from charcoal to
Co so I am not a scientist I read you
scientific documents I will be happy to
provide all of that to you just so you
can understand where the when you're
putting things in the environment and
how they impact yeah I can't I'm not
going to be able to to answer answer
that question I'm just not I will be
able to provide you an answer to that
question though representative Noel has
a question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question uh I assume that
the uh pilots and the crew that are
putting together these chemicals have
looked at the msdss for graphine oxide
or the aluminum oxide or all of the
other components and they've made the
determinations as to what the lethal
dose is and what the correct
concentration needs to be when they go
to distribute these chemicals otherwise
they would be in violation of Osha
law um the the federal study that I will
give you that just came out in in 2024
will um be very will show you that there
is no monitoring uh there we don't know
any of that information at all um we
don't know who these Pilots are or any
of that so this is its think of it like
uh you know think of it like its own you
know space force NASA or whatever
there're there there's an own entity
here that's running that's separate from
all regulation there's no government or
Federal Regulation in any of this right
now at all that is the reason why we're
like I said earlier it's like the Wild
Wild West so there is
nothing representative Ms has a question
thank you uh Mr chairman
um um I I was going to follow up on on
representative kaplan's comments but I I
I I I do need to ask you a question in
light of what you just said um so what
evidence is there that these flights
have actually taken place do we have any
record of takeoffs Landings flight
Hampshire so there is a gentleman that
is um he's a former pilot uh former
military that has been tracking planes
out of P's Air Force Base he couldn't be
here today to testify so so all flight
records of course we you know um this is
coming from a I'm not a pilot so I don't
know the terms so that he there's
different tracking mechanisms that you
can see where flight records are and
where where planes are going so um some
some planes of course are on you know
they're just normal you know uh take off
whatever where they're going that then
there's a military entity of course to
pece but those are on a different
tracking mechanism as well um for all
the recorded flights so there are
flights that he that he has documented
that there is no documentation at all so
they're not showing takeoff Landings or
any of that kind of stuff cuz he's there
he's been following this for a very long
time but there's many other entities all
throughout the United States that I will
connect you with followup followup so I
I I live in in Hampton I live um a half
mile from the water um I see the planes
taking off and landing at peas all the
time um I have never seen a plane like
you have described in this handout um so
I I mean are you suggesting that the
flights are originating at
peace I'm not I'm not suggesting in that
they're originating from peas I'm
suggesting that they could be
originating from anywhere but there's
been multiple flights where you can see
[Music]
um you can see literally emissions
coming out of a plane that are that stay
it's not a contrail or anything like
that and I don't like to use you know
I'm not going to use the that dirty word
that people like to talk about cuz then
we're all like you know oh with this is
some big conspiracy because it is not
and it's been going on for a long time
why would Mexico why why would why would
Mexico ban this why is the United States
the only one that um basically said hey
we're not going to be part of that out
of 190 other countries that are that are
have basically said no we're not going
to pollute with Geo you know we're not
going to experiment on um you know on
our citizens so this stuff is happening
it's been happening
there's I see planes all of the time
that are not just regular planes
so this is literally
taken from our government so this is the
um the NOAA chemical Sciences laboratory
they are part of the US Department of
Commerce they are also part of the
national ocean Oceanic Atmospheric
Administration and part of the ocean
office of Oceanic and Atmospheric
research Department n o AA o a r so this
isn't I'm not pulling these you know
up to follow up on representative mun's
question how do you tell the difference
between a regular plane and a plane
that's doing whatever it is you're
suggesting that they're doing
you can see it
from you can see it right from the
ground so I mean I have of course
pictures on my phone they
leave they leave a white they do leave a
white Trail for a long period of time
and then it dissipates into like
sometimes it's like ribbon kind of
looking clouds that are it's really hard
to describe but there's um
there's a document
here that I gave you guys that's what it
looks
like okay thank you representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative Penza for taking my
question um I think we we are not
environment nag right so we don't get a
lot of the bills that are about um
pollution and additives in water and
land I think you guys see most of those
and we do definitely have um um an issue
with thank you um we definitely do have
an issue with contaminants in our
environment now that we're all concerned
about and they're they're kind of hard
to um to localize in some ways because I
don't know if any of you have ever heard
that New England is called the tailpipe
of the US because the wind flows from
west to east and we get a lot of
contaminants from o from other areas
Industrial Waste in the midwest it it
flows this way so my question is you're
you're naming contaminants but I am
wondering how you know that these
contaminants are
related first of all how do you know
that these contaminants are here and
second how do you know these
contaminants are related to
geoengineering versus some other way of
getting here which I would I would
imagine our Dees person might be able to
speak to that too how they get here
right CU you're making you're trying to
make the connection and say this is what
it's from and this is how we know so I
know so I I've got eyes to see right so
I've seen this uh um I've seen this on
my own uh I know I have constituents
that have contacted the Department of
Environmental Services and received
um no answer uh their answer
Dees has no knowledge of anyone spraying
chemicals into the atmosphere from
aircraft other than exhaust gases from
combustion and fuel aircraft Dees
understands that some limited testing or
research may have occurred in this field
but we have no specific information
related to such testing and are not
aware of it currently occurring in New
Hampshire elsewhere Dees is aware of the
statutory requirements contained in RSA
12f so they're not looking into it
there's been con there's been multiple
constituents that have called on this
that have asked for it to be looked at
um so all I know is that I have eyes to
see I know what they look
like that is what from the NOAA it tells
you what's get gets
released um into the
atmosphere and that's really when you're
it's in a sense it's playing God is
really what it comes down to we are
we're messing with things that we
shouldn't be messing with and it affects
everything from ecosystems to People's
Health to all of that but if we can find
out that information then we need to
find that
out followup so I I I agree with you you
know it's a little scary to think that
people are messing with things they may
not understand the outcomes of I I agree
with that I have that same feeling about
geoengineering I just just think that um
we're trying to prove a negative here
right we're saying that our Department
of Environmental Services doesn't know
about any activity and they should
because we know there is activity but
you haven't provided any real evidence
of activity and so I'm I'm just trying
to figure out if you understand how the
system is supposed to work right the any
geoengineering that's happening in the
country is authorized at the federal
level and requested at the state level
which means we have to assume that that
the proposal that you're putting out
here is that someone other than those
entities somebody is deciding to seed
the clouds over New Hampshire without
anybody's knowledge and I
don't I just I don't know how you how
you um how you want us to to go along
with you on that because somebody has to
be behind it
and so is it is it the federal
government is that what you're trying to
say that the federal government is doing
this to us correct without our input
correct that's just clear as day well
the record of all of the Geo seeding
that's happened in the United States has
been at the states requests that had
that Geo seating though whether it's
California or Colorado the the places
that are listed as the places that have
had it from the research that I've done
remember uh representative we're not
here to well I'm just trying to get an
idea because I don't know how the
process you're talking about where a
state and that's you're talking about
something separate so you're talking
about if a state is requiring or asking
for the federal government to do some to
you do some cloud seating in regards
with like the that's happened in
multiple places that have been affected
by drought um and all of that that's not
what we're talking about so we're
talking about literally the federal
government that is doing full-blown
experimentation and it it's all I'll
send you every single document that you
need it's all right out there for you to
find and in my press release that I did
that has been picked up everywhere
um right on www white house.gov
congressionally mandated report on solar
radiation modification that's what this
bill is it talks about
SRM so it it's a huge report and then
I'll give you studies from um actually
Dartmouth has a study uh UNH is is
familiar with this I've already talked
to my folks over there um I have someone
that's willing to pay um after rainfall
when when we have witnesses that are
seeing a lot of the um a lot of the um a
lot of the cloud formations that we're
talking about from from aircraft um to
test the ground and to test the rainfall
afterwards um so there's a lot of people
that are very very interested in this
however we can prove this to make it
happen but when it comes this is the
federal government this is there's no um
there's no regul there's nothing's being
experiments representative clog has a
question thank you chair and thank you
for taking my question um I'm a segue
off of um other reps
now we see the I can see the weather
changing in my
lifetime in this committee I hear it's
CO2 methane we've taken sulfur out of
our diesel fuels we taken the
particulates out of our diesel fuels and
what I heard today from testimony that
we're putting sulfur dioxide U sulfur
dioxide um and um graphite carbon in the
air
now these same things are attributing to
health of this um our citizens
so U my question is if there is a study
committee you can provide documents it's
a question can you provide documents to
to
prove or identify where this is
happening 100% thank
you representative Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um so this
bill starts off in the air literally
you're talking about planes and
everything and then on page four it kind
of brings it down to the Earth where
you're talking about facilities and
towers and
antennas um and you're saying that any
facility Tower or antenna that uses
ionizing radiation has um concentrated
energy
Transmissions exposure to um people
could an unintended consequence of this
bill be that it could shut down seab
Brook power stations and 5G
Towers no so if
[Music]
um let me grab my I have a piece of
that and of course if there needs to be
an amendment to this bill in any way cuz
you know it's not perfect this is a um
it's kind of a monster of a bill and uh
we had a lot of experts help with this
um with its crafting of course um but
that it could be changed you know if
there was any um if there was any
question to that where am I looking a
followup there it is
oh do you have an answer for that
yes so I just wanted to um I wanted to
let you know that uh folks that are all
about 5G 6G and all of that kind of
stuff uh which is you know the huge
corporations like Verizon and all of
that they all support this because this
has interference with their frequencies
so what's happening when you are when
you are um making it like a you know
aluminum dust or heavy metals that are
that are taking place in the atmosphere
it also affects that so um so Verizon
18t so I'm going to actually quote them
um so even Verizon and AT&T Define what
we're referring to as pollution to be
clear we're not you know worried about
snow making cannons like we talked about
um we're looking to regulate airplane
engine emissions have you know some and
we're not looking that's the other thing
is like everybody keeps talking about
domestic airplane engine emissions and
that's that's all disingenuous but for
Verizon and AT&T to come out and say
that what that this is pollution and it
affects their operations is quite big
okay
followup followup thank you um and on uh
page four line 26 you reference ecode
360 can you tell me what that is please
no probably can't page what uh it's page
four of the bill line
26 uh any vibration noise I think that's
laser not CER is CER okay uh Sonic
weapon or other physical agent exceeding
other official limits guidelines or
standards such as eode
360 is what is
that I'm sorry what line are you on I
okay so I can provide some of that
information to you um I EOD 360 is is uh
that is a um that's a federal uh that's
a federal code so as you know that um
our government has been um developing
and has for decades as well Sonic
weapons laser weapons all of that from
from satellites and everything that you
could possibly imagine so um there's a
there's a document and I'm pretty sure
it's from UCLA that talks about how and
this is getting very very technical um
where the satellite um coordinates of
course with what's being released in the
atmosphere and that actually creates um
that actually creates in a sense kind of
a a weapon um an environmental weapon
that is taking place too but this is way
beyond my pay
grade I went to school for
communications I'm a minor in public
relations I'm hope I'm doing thank you
so um repres pres ative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I'm I'm a bit
concerned about U some of the assertions
that you've made so you you said that um
sulfur dioxide and sulfuric acid are
causes of asthma you stated a link
between aluminum and Alzheimer's and I
took the liberty of going to the
American Lung Association site and they
have a page called what causes asthma
and it lists family history allergies
viral respiratory infections
occupational exposur smoking air
pollution and under air pollution it
says exposure to the main component of
smog ozone raises the risk for asthma
and then obesity nowhere is anything
about sulfur dioxide mentioned you just
mentioned it you just mentioned air
pollution that's what we're talking
about well you mentioned Su dioxide
specifically and there's nothing here
about that and then um I'm also at the
uh Lung Association site uh not excuse
me Alzheimer's Association site and uh
it says and I'm quoting no convincing
relationship between aluminum and the
development of Alzheimer's disease has
been established so um are you are you
contradicting these authoritative sites
I'm not contradicting I I'm but I'm
going to I'll give you other
authoritative sites everybody wants to
say they're an expert on everything but
I'm going to give you literally other
medical sites that state um High toxic
levels of aluminum in that load how it
does have those types of effects which
it has other types of effects as well
aluminum has effects with respiratory as
well aluminum has effects with um with
neurological different components
especially um in in young children so
um yeah I I'll give you everything that
you need in regards with health but do
you know what the uh leading cause of of
um second leading cause of lung cancer
country uh according to who in not ask
the questions of you not the other way
around okay so it's raidon so and and
actually that's why if you want to talk
about cancer rates and all of that kind
of stuff here in New Hampshire we have a
huge problem and that's not just with
radon in the water that's radon in the
air so um yeah we I'm very familiar with
um with those types of pollutants okay
representative Penza I want to thank you
for your
testimony and uh give the last word of
this public hearing to Mr Craig Wright
of the the department of En
Environmental Services once um Mr Wright
has spoken with us we're going to recess
22nd
us well you would have been able to
speak except representative Penza who
asked for 10 minutes spoke for 50 and
she took up all our time and stop
I'm not going to stop somebody who's a
representative so repres Mr Craig Wright
please uh take the uh could I ask why
not why not instead of you guys have you
don't have another bill after this you
have an executive session or work
session right we do we have both and we
have members who need to leave you so
we're GNA ask Mr Wright to give us his
legislation thank you Mr chair again
Craig Wright I serve as the Director of
the air division at the Department of
Environmental Services a pleasure to be
here
today um there's a lot in this bill um
as you've heard already um I think if
you read the fiscal note that the
department wrote I think it's
clear is this better okay sorry um Dees
does not have expertise knowledge or any
other information regarding the subject
topics of this bill nor do we have any
information regarding potential Health
impacts or environmental
impacts um Dees as noted in the fiscal
note Dees does not have the staff
resources to research monitor or for
Force the provisions of this
bill we would need to hire technical
staff investigative staff and
enforcement
staff regardless of all that um and I
think this is also noted in the fiscal
note from the Department of Justice I
would question whether um even with this
bill uh the state would have
jurisdiction over things that may be
federally
regulated
um this type of work is not typical to
the work that thees performs under our
air pollution control statutes RSA
125c or the federal Clean Air Act under
the federal Clean Air Act EPA sets
health-based air quality standards it's
the state's responsibility to monitor
the equality with respect to those
standards and if we don't meet those
standards we need to develop plans
policies programs uh to ensure that the
state meets those standards um we need
to submit such plans to EPA for approval
um also in reading the bill I would
think that there's a things that we
would need to consult with the AG's
office on regarding the enforcement
Provisions including issu and cease and
desist orders um there are emergency air
pollution episode provisions of
125c um but I don't know that that would
qualify as a cease and desist
order I would have to consult with the
AG's office on our ability to notify
federal agencies of doing things if if
authorized by the federal government
and the same goes with notifying foreign
States or International bodies of
potential activities under the bill I
have we have another number of technical
issues with the bill um regarding some
of the specific Provisions I'm not sure
how we would Implement them um I'll just
use as an example the bill States Dees
shall post advertisements in newspapers
and other websites encouraging the
public to monitor measured document and
report that requirement is is unclear to
me and not very specific I don't know
how I would satisfy that requirement
without further guidance it talks about
submitting photographs videos
audiography lab tests microscopy
spectroscopy meter unsure what Dees
would do with those pieces of
information um I I I don't know that a
single photograph of a of a airplane in
the sky um would be evidence of
anything
um I guess the only other thing I would
say is with respect to the uh resource
load of this bill um there certainly is
no revenues associated with this bill
and I can guarantee you that I do not
have the staff to do that without a
revenue
Source thank you do you have any
estimate at all of what it might end up
costing to
enforce the provisions of this bill what
it might cost agency given our lack of
expertise and knowledge in this area I
think I think we estimated in the fiscal
note it could be upwards of 10
staff I I I can't sit here today and say
I can guarantee that could it be five
maybe could it be 15
committee representative
muns thank you Mr chair thank you for uh
for coming in um I I think you already
answered the question but I want to just
be very very sure I understood do
correctly to your knowledge there are no
published reports that um document any
of what is um what we've heard has been
happening in New Hampshire there's no
documentation of that available that you
know we we could
review I I personally am not aware of
any such reports that appear reviewed
scientific studies um I've heard it
mentioned here today that such reports
exist I I am not aware of them and I do
them followup please uh keep your
comments to yourself thank you
representative Ms you need a followup
followup yeah I I I would just ask that
um if there are reports available um
that um they be forwarded to us but um
that they be specific to experience in
New Hampshire I'm not really interested
in knowing what happened in
California additional questions
representative Thomas thank you Mr chair
um as as um someone who works in the uh
Department of Air uh resources do you
does New Hampshire or I'm sorry oh the
director
sorry um in New Hampshire do you test
for sulfur uh chemicals and graphite
chemicals so so in the air thank you for
the question um in New Hampshire we
operate a network of I think 13
monitoring
sites
we monitor for sulfur dioxide at three
sites in New Hampshire one in Penbrook
one in um top of Pacman adock and um the
other one in londonairy we also monitor
for ozone at a number of sites across
the state uh we monitor for
certain ozone precursor organic
compounds at two sites in the state I
could certainly provide to the committee
um what we monitor for and where we
monitor it um representative gearhard
mentioned particular matter we do
monitor for a particular matter at six
sites across the state um three of those
sites are filter-based
sites um we do not monitor those filters
for chemical composition we simply weigh
them for the amount of particular matter
that is collected we're measuring all
those up against what we call the
Federal National ambient air quality
standards follow up follow up and are
you seeing an increase in any um any
particular uh component in general
long-term pollution trends for the
pollutants that we monitor for are
decreasing over
time I'm sorry you say they're
decreasing decreasing over time um one
uh
this past summer with the wildfires up
in Canada we probably saw some very
extreme PM events uh particularly to our
South and West not necessarily here in
New Hampshire um but that is certainly
something we monitor for and we we
prepare periodically an annual what we
call stateof the air report and I could
certainly make that available to the
committee as well thank you
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you uh uh
Mr R for coming uh to follow up on
representative mun's question about your
knowledge of of ongoing programs in the
area of geoengineering going on anywhere
in the continental United States do you
have any knowledge of such research
programs going on or carried out by the
federal government dealing with airplane
emissions having to do with
geoengineering do have you seen any you
know National Oceanic and Atmospheric
agency anything any federal agency is
doing that kind of research I am not
aware of it I haven't seen it I haven't
looked for it
though additional questions for Mr
Wright representative McGee thank you
are you are you that Mr Wright no I'm
just kidding my mother always told me
I'm Mr could use a little
break you can ask my ex-wife so so my
question that's funny um see you had the
less left that's great um Okay so so my
question goes back to something I was
questioning before which is that a lot
of times we have folks come into the
committee room who aren't really sure
how um there are many systems involved
and many people making decisions up and
down the ladder and everyone isn't
always you know is isn't always aware of
that my understanding is that the state
of New Hampshire would have to be
consulted if there was going to be any
type of geoengineering over us and so I
would like you
to chime in on that if you're aware of
that in terms of just the governmental
hierarchy I I can't say that I could you
don't know I don't know okay I hate I
thanks okay any other questions seeing
none I want to thank you Mr Wright for
being here toh testify and we'll look
forward to the information you can send
us about air quality in New Hampshire
and with that we're going to recess this
public public hearing until Monday the
22nd of January at 100
p.m. 1 p.m. January
22nd so we're going to take a five
minute break and then we're going to
come back for a short work session and
then an executive session on Two Bills
committee
one one
hour yep I have 10 cards and in one hour
I can let uh 10 people have five
minutes you don't ask a lot of questions
one correct
correct however if I start hearing
repetitive testimony then I'm going to
reduce the amount of time allowed to two
minutes
please uh come up here if you want to
address
us
on House Bill
FN relative to energy procurement
agreements for default
service
and I would like to
ask representative Bernardi wherever he
went to oh there he
is I'd like to ask representative
Bernardi to uh make a few comments
before we have a discussion amongst the
rest of the committee about this this
Bill thank you Mr chairman uh rep clog
is handing out our um
some
uh sheets which indicate the uh well
there's three of them one you saw last
last time we met on this bill which is
the uh the cost of Power by eversource
in New Hampshire and and uh
Massachusetts and what the how the rates
went up and down the second two are the
costs of natural gas uh one says natural
gas US Dollars mm
BTUs um and the cost is going from0 to
$10 on the right hand side you see it
peaks in August uh around
$95 August of 22 that is uh the second
is natural gas Dutch TTC that's how they
uh in Euros per megawatt hour that's how
they uh Co do their GS gas costing um
and I've written at the top of that
August Peak that equates to
$72 per uh um uh million uh BTUs uh
equating it to the US equivalent so 9
and a half in the US at the peak
72 in Europe at the peak Mr
chairman yes I'm sorry to interrupt
representative Berard we don't have this
information in front of us yet and it
would be really helpful as as you're
narrating about it to have it so can you
is it possible to just hold up for a
moment until we have it two seconds okay
just suspend for a second while we get
this material pass
out
yeah there there should be three sheets
one is one is the eversource rates New
Hampshire and Massachusetts with the red
and blue lines that we saw last
session last committee meeting excuse me
the second is natural gas in the EU has
bucks and the third is natural gas
prices in the
three okay I got one now you want got
one yeah okay you have another one send
[Music]
fun are we
so I have
mine
there should be a couple extra and I
are so uh the
reason I I did this was to try to
understand in Greater
granularity the first uh sheet that we
got from uh the DOE last committee
meeting which gave the New Hampshire and
Massachusetts rates and showed that
tremendous doubling in New
Hampshire uh around the August time
frame this these other two documents
explain that whereas most most gas in
the US is at the at the US rate which
obviously went up significantly we do
get the residual or the EXT that we need
uh from
um uh by boat uh and that reflects the
European rate so that's why we're also
influenced by that uh that costing as
well and you see that it did Peak
significantly in August up the
$72 so um having listened to uh the Pu
and the doe last uh committee meeting uh
I thought it a appropriate uh to
continue to evaluate this uh they were
not very sanguin on the bill that was
proposed I would I asked uh assistant
commissioner uh Elms this morning
whether doe could model the impact of uh
changing our electric rates still having
standard six-month contracts yet do it
on a quarterly basis so every quarter
one half of the contracts that are that
need to be renewed get reviewed if they
modeled uh what the likely cost would be
to our rates based on that kind of
approach with the natural gas prices
being the driver um would that show that
we would not have paid as much for as
long by my unsophisticated eyeball
not not any mathematical modeling I
would say yes it
would um so I'm interested in seeing
whether that approach would work that is
not going full laddering and allowing
contracts of all kinds of differential
rates and and whatnot but a a
programmatic approach of uh uh quarterly
rate setting half of the contracts up
each quarter would that have been a
benefit to New Hampshire rate payers um
so that modeling uh
again your boss said is okay so um I'm
GNA ask that Doe would do that um and if
that shows a benefit then I would
suggest that we um amend the bill to
reflect that and I and also I'm
sensitive to what I heard last uh
committee meeting that we not prescribe
that as the defined and only method but
that we allow the
uh that approach or other approaches be
used that would have the opportunity to
drive our prices closer to Market rates
and
therefore minimize imp PS uh that a
long-term contract has in keeping rates
elevated so that's that's my my thought
here um and as far as I'm concerned we
can discuss whether that makes sense and
and if it does then I would propose this
bill go to interim study to get that
information we also I think should get
Doe's promised report on this issue
before we take any um any new bill up or
an amended Bill
up okay thank you I would concur with
you that referring this bill for interim
study would probably be the best way to
go because there are many many
unanswered questions here and a lot of
data Gathering that needs to be done to
fully understand this issue
representative
Thomas um thank you um thank you for
clarifying uh this bill a little bit
more um in my notes from from the
hearing I wrote uh risk premium is the
culprit so how does the change that
you're talking about right now how does
premium well well the the spikes that
you see
are are risk premium driven
to some extent particularly the giant
spikes I mean that that's uh that's a
response to different activities that
are occurring in the world at the time
and you see it drops off significantly
after the those spikes occur that's the
risk is now considered less urgent and
less compelling and therefore the price
is dropping back to a more normal Market
Market uh level so
um as I suggested the approach of of
having defined contracts uh done on a
quarterly basis half of them each
quarter um I I think just by ey takes
some of that risk premium off the table
but I would like to see that modeled to
verify my assumption I don't I can't
swear to you that that's truth
representative Harrington has a comment
uh yeah thank you um a couple of
comments actually uh first with the risk
premium changing it it reduces that
doesn't reduce the RIS risk premium but
reduces the amount of the load that's
subject to that because you're going to
break it up into two separate contracts
that are going to be half the load for
this six-month period and have to load
for another so if you were in a period
of highrisk Premium because it would be
basically the you know more or less the
same because you're looking into the
future that's what sets the risk premium
so if there was a high spike in there it
would only affect half the load so it
wouldn't be as impactful of course when
the prices go down you would only get it
going down for half the load so I mean
it's a balance um this was done in the
days before uh Public Service had
divested all of their generation the
other utilities like Unitil and Liberty
did come in with contracts where it was
for I think it was 50% of their load I
may not be sure but I I know they had
them staggered like that in the past now
why they stopped doing that I don't know
I just I I wasn't at the Pu when it when
that occurred so but again I want to get
back to the point here I I understand
the inim study which I think is a good
idea I'm not sure that there's much
we're still talking about that the Pu
doesn't already have the authority to do
if they wanted to go to splitting them
up into you know 50% of the load
contracts uh and staggered the starting
uh times of those I think they have the
authority to do that but there seems to
be enough questions so I would I could
certainly approve uh go along with uh
inum study and then get all of those
answered get the report that your that U
representative was referring to back and
uh we can go forward from there yeah the
uh the concept of uh
um the Pu being able to do this on their
own I I I did hear them say that that's
potentially an opportunity that's why
I'm not proposing that we do something
foolish and cement in approach but keep
the opportunity for the puc open and to
also you know if some other brilliant
idea comes up they have the opportunity
to uh Implement
that representative Ms has a comment
um I'm I'm glad you said that because um
I I'm you know I was I I'm wondering
whether other members of the committee
took a look at the amendment that uh
eversource had proposed or the language
that eversource had proposed which I
think does what you just said you were
hoping to do which is kind of keeps it
keeps it like wide open it doesn't set a
prescription that says it's got to be
every six months and it's got to be
50% um so I mean I after I read that
proposed language I thought that made
some sense and keeps our options open so
I just was curious what others felt
I I agree with the eversource approach
does keep the options open for best uh
practices further
comments representative McGee this was
just kind of a clarification I was
looking at my notes as well and I had
the note um that the that the utilities
can already pursue lading and that the
Pu already has the latitude to make uh
their review more frequent if or you
know they can they can schedule things
how it makes the most sense so I don't
think we need to step into those
processes but I think the interim stud
is a good idea and the thing I wanted to
make comment on was I guess maybe I'm
all on an island but my understanding of
the risk premium was that if if uh if a
buyer enters into a long-term contract
the risk premium often has something to
do with taking into account the fact
that the market May fluctuate over the
course of that contract right so if
everybody's paying 4 cents um they may
make it six cents or a little high you
know they may say I can give you this
for 20 years but I I can't go below that
because I have to build in the risk of
the fact that the prices could go up so
the length of the contract also
contributes to both stability which we
had that language in here right that we
wanted price stability and also uh
whether somebody can actually guarantee
you that they can give you that that
price over time so it's there's a lot
here to study and I don't think we're
ready to pass a bill that has language
in it that that everybody could live
with I concur that's why I think inter
studies
appropriate all right other comments
representative
cren thank you turbos thanks for taking
my question
um I guess just going back to last year
some of the things that we heard I could
swear that we heard testimony that part
of the reason that Community power was
able to kind of keep their rates a
little bit flatter than um eversource
and Liberty was because they were
allowed to pursue this approach and the
other utilities weren't so I feel like
I'm a little bit confused about now the
idea that actually they always did have
this power because I feel like we heard
alternatively that they didn't and I'm
sorry if I'm not articulating this very
well but can someone tell me that I'm
not crazy or how I was misunderstanding
that testimony last
year I don't think you're crazy I I I I
I I think I I think that was one of the
arguments that Community power made and
I think eversource came to the table and
said we have an order from the P that we
have to do this every six months so
they're operating that way now I don't
you
Liberty and Unitil I don't know if they
have an order doing it but that's how
they do
it yes followup so it was a pu order but
now we're understanding that the Pu can
change that order or relax that order
whenever they want to and that would
solve the problem their testimony was
that they have the capability to uh
order
Vice chair Thomas has a comment thank
you Mr chair thank you so I'm I'm just I
just want to clarify something you said
earlier you at the one hand you said you
think interim study is might be a good
way to go for this bill but then you
also mentioned that you thought that the
eversource amendment uh was something
that uh was much better and could be
pursued so which which is
it I think the interim study can look at
the words in the eversource amendment as
well as what comes out of the doe report
and then have a full discussion and see
what's the best bill that we can come up
with follow up followup okay so
essentially then uh you're not
recommending uh any bill go forward this
year then you're going to wait for
interim study to basically say yes we
need more legislation or no we don't for
bium no I think we can have an interim
study this year and hopefully get
something done the doe bill is supposed
doe report supposed to be coming out
shortly so hopefully we could have this
done by what we have to have it done by
uh mid-march is that correct so the way
interim study works is if we put this
bill into interim study then we can
decide as a committee whether we want to
do any further interim study work on it
whether we do or not come November we're
going to have to issue a report that
says we recommend this bill for this for
additional legislation or we do not
recommend this for additional
legislation and usually there's a
rationale that's attached to that
recommendation so if in November we
decide that future leg legislation is
warranted then we should provide a
written La rationale for why we believe
that future legislation is
needed to get there we probably would
have to have a couple of meetings uh to
study this uh in the interim between now
and next
November representative
Harrington thank you Mr chair I just
wanted to be clear on the risk premium
we've been kind of tossing that term
around so the people the main
uh source of the risk premium is the
day-to-day supply of electricity so it
really doesn't make too much difference
how longterm the contract is because
you're going to be locked into prices so
if you make it longer you may see that
the supplier might say well I don't know
what the gas prices are going to be a
year from now so I have to build in a
little bit more of my contract just in
case they're higher than I expect but
the other part of that is on any given
day it can be rainy orow know or sunnier
colder whatever than was expected and
because of that you have to have a risk
premium built in to make sure you have
enough generation there's going to be
times when the supplier is paying
someone not to generate electricity
because it's a warmer day or it's a
cooler day than expected and it's less
air conditioning load and it's raining
out or whatever so that's that's part of
the risk premium it's it's not only just
the risk of going forward uh on the
contracts because most of those
contracts get locked up the supplier who
who signs the contract with utility is
going to have a contract with generators
and they're going to give them more or
less a fixed price but we no one knows
what the weather is going to be 6 months
from now and that's what the real risk
premium is built in and it's that 247
365 matching load to
comments representative L Wiki uh thank
you Mr chairman um might it me more
appropriate to do something like tabling
rather than interm study basically defer
this until we have a little bit more
information but not um you know do a
formal interm St
study well a committee can't table a
bill we could defer an exec
session but I don't see personally any
need to do that because uh I don't think
there's any part of this bill that would
be worthwhile going forward with and if
If all we're going to do is study this
question then we can do that by
study
okay representative Kennedy did you have
a comment yeah uh JD were you were you
thinking this could be done by March
because can you end an interim study
early I mean can you issue the report
you know in a by March and then have an
amendment and somehow get it get it to
the General Session well I understand a
normal circumstances interim study
reports I due in March before the next
election that's that's but I I
did think that potentially if all all
stars aligned we could have something
that we could work on before the house
bills all have to cross over but that
probably is a an error on my part yes
you misspoke you said March you meant
November yes that's when as a matter of
fact the way this works is once we
submit this bill for interim study the
clerk and the speaker will not let us
touch it again until next
fall it'll be off limits until fall so
we late
summer uh Vice chair Thomas yeah um just
not to money the water but just to
rephrase uh what the chair just said
interim
study if effectively kills the bill for
this year the study can we can do a
study which will only produce a
recommendation whether or not there can
be legislation or not and then
information from that study could be
used to write a new bill next bium by
whoever happens to be here at the time
so that's so effectively nothing will
happen with inum study except to come up
with a little report on why we should go
forward or or not so that's to be be
clear
okay okay I think that gives us an
opportunity now to open an executive
FN and I will recognize representative
Bernardi for a
motion as soon as he gets back to his
seat thank you Mr chair I move interim
study chair recognizes Vice chair
Thomas second it's been moved and
seconded that we refer House Bill 1617
FN for interim study Is there further
discussion representative Thomas thank
you Mr chair um my only question is
there was discussion of the eversource
amendment um is there agreement on that
can we go forward no there's not okay
okay um good I'm good thank you
discussion seeing none it appears that
we can ask the
clerk if he's ready to call the
role on the question of refer for
interim study House
17- FN I don't know if I can drag this
out any
longer relative to energy procurement
service VI chairman uh
Thomas yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative lyi yes representative
Bry yes representative Berardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers not here correct uh
representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
MC Williams yes representative
cran
yes representative parall yes
representative Kaplan yes representative
muns yes representative Noel yes
representative Thomas yes yes
representative Corman yes represent
representative rolds yes chairman Vose
zero the committee uh refers hb1 1617
dfn for interim study without objection
this will be placed on the consent
calendar and representative Bernardi
will write the committee
report and because committee reports are
due to the house
clerk by noon on Wednesdays I'm going to
have to ask representative Bernardi to
stay here until he finishes writing his
report
okay and with that we'll end the
executive session on House Bill 1616 7-
FN and now I'm going to open an
executive session on a house bill
1627 by agreement with the ranking
member we're going
to pass judgment on House Bill 1627 Rel
which we heard earlier today relative to
rodifer railroads transportation and
Telecommunications and I recognize
representative Bernardi for a
motion I move out to pass I recognize
Vice chair
Thomas yes the
second it's been moved and seconded that
we judge House Bill 1627 to be worthy of
ought to pass and let me just say that
because this is essentially a
housekeeping bill that just moves
statutes from one title to another
there's nothing controversial about it
there's nothing partisan about it it's
strictly a
uh a housekeeping measure and so I would
urge you all to support the the motion
about to pass any further
discussion representative Corbin thank
you uh I worked with chair Vose on this
and I could not agree
more thank you representative reels
thank you Mr chair I just think we
should express our appreciation to you
and representative Corman for doing what
was surely some tedious work in uh in
getting this all down for us it was a
tad tedious I will admit and and it was
chair Vose who shouldered the tedious
part of the
comment seeing none I'd ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of ought
1627 Vice chair Thomas
yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative
wrong
form
uh it's an old form with the wrong names
on
it uh representative Kennedy yes
representative Wicky yes representative
brne yes yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
McGee yes representative
McWilliams yes representative crean yes
representative
parshall yes representative Kaplan yes
representative uh muns yes
representative Noel yes representative
Thomas yes representative Corman yes
representative
rolds
yes chairman Vose
Z by a vote of 19 to nothing the
committee um adopts the motion of ought
to pass on HB
1627 without objection it'll go on the
consent
calendar okay with that we'll close the
executive session on House Bill 1627 who
will write the OTP
report uh representative Bernardi will
write the committee report but I will
help
him wonderful so now we need to talk
about our our committee work over the
next couple of
weeks as you know we missed yesterday
because it was a state holiday and next
week the Tuesday of next week is primary
election day so we've been told we can't
schedule committee meetings on that
day so next Monday the 22nd of January
at 9 o'l in the morning we're going to
have a one-hour presentation on Forest
carbon credits by Charles
LC immediately following that
presentation we're going to continue the
or resume the public caring on House
Bill
1697 which is a bill that seeks to
suspend Forest carbon
credits and due to the large number of
pink cards that we had when we sus when
we recessed that public hearing last
week I'm going to hold two hours for
that public hearing so from 10 to to
um to 12 will'll have time for that
public hearing on 1697 then we'll take a
break for lunch and then at 1:00 we're
going to come back and have a 2hour
public hearing on HB 1700 the bill that
we started to hear earlier
today and I will likely schedule at
least one maybe two other hearings after
that um in the hope that we can squeeze
them in but because we can't meet on
Tuesday next week I I'd like to get more
than just two bills done next week if
possible that means that on the 29th and
30th of January which are a Monday and a
Tuesday we're going to fill up the
calendar on both days with bills and
executive sessions work sessions and
executive sessions so I don't haven't
got that mapped out exactly just yet
because the schedule's a little flu with
all the uh multi-hour sessions that I'm
having to schedule here but uh as soon
as I know what we're doing I'll let you
guys know but please hold in reserves
Monday Tuesday the 29th and 30th for
committee
days and that's uh what we're looking at
going forward Vice chair
Thomas yes Todd question for the chair
um my recommendation might be just to
play it safe for Monday can we perhaps
on HP 1700 schedule an hour and a half
uh for the bill uh this way uh if we do
finish early uh we'll have a little more
time to to pick up two other bills that
really we need to look at that's a good
idea
yeah representative Thomas yes so are
you anticipating by um the 30th that
bills
it's possible but I'm not sure we can
fit them all in so if you if you don't
mind me ask what what's what's the rush
I mean some committees are just meeting
for the first time well the only Rush is
the speaker has requested that we get
bills to him in a timely manner so that
he can hold regular Thursday sessions he
told us this morning in a chairs meeting
that was in this room right before this
committee room uh this Committee hearing
that he wants to have house sessions all
four of the first four Thursdays of
February okay so in order for him to be
able to do that we have to fill up the
pipeline with bills and when I say we I
mean all house committees not just s&
but we want to do our fair share we want
to do our part so I'm trying to get
stuff
done uh in as timely a fashion as I
can
and the idea that that we
can take a lot of time to do these bills
and do it in a casual fashion that's the
kind of attitude that puts us in the
untenable position of having to have
three long session days at in the middle
of March at the end of March no we're
trying to avoid that I understand that
um but we've had two hearings now that
have had to be stopped early because so
many people have shown up so I I just
you know at what point do we balance
moving these bills out of our committee
with with hearing what people have to
them it's typically what happens is you
just do that on a case-by Case basis
like I had no idea that HB 1700 was
going to be oh I knew that I didn't
because the sponsors never contacted me
uh in fact I got a telephone call from
one of the sponsors
on uh Saturday this just this past
Saturday saying you scheduled this bill
for for
Monday we need more time we're bringing
in uh people to testify from Texas you
got to give us more time and I said to
that person well you didn't call me
ahead of time I had no idea that there
was some kind of a time constraint on
this bill
so I'm doing the best I can but I'm not
perfect I make uh judgments judgment
calls and sometimes they're right
sometimes they're not that's all I can
say y thank
you Vice chair Thomas yes uh also should
we should we finish earlier than normal
uh and we have enough time to work on
these bills and we may have extra time
maybe if we have to schedule more time
for them being upfront allows us to be
able to go later on to cover bills that
may we need more time but in addition by
somewhat finishing early when we can
gives us opportunity perhaps to have
some presentations here uh which are
long we haven't had the ones that we
normally had to have pre pandemic and so
this gives us an opportunity now to to
hear things that normally even freshman
here would have
heard representative MC
Williams thank you so much for the
information on um having house session
Thursdays in February I noticed that the
calendar for February actually has five
Thursdays so do you mean that the first
Thursday which is the 1 of February
would be the first house session just
for calendaring
purposes yes the only Thursday that the
speaker didn't want to schedule was the
last one because that's during school
vacation week Le here the 29th all right
thank
you anything else representative
parshall yes thank you for your work I
first appreciate that and um I'm also
glad that we're trying to keep the
Speaker of the House happy um is there
any possibility of getting a little uh
alteration of our house calendar to move
St so we're not always last in the
day I've been asking for that ever since
I've been a chair and have bumped up
against the stone wall every time okay
it's good answer not the one I want but
so along those lines uh representative n
made a suggestion a long time ago that
we change our committee name to energy
and that would solve the
problem that's not a bad idea we would
have to go to the rules committee
because the names of the Committees are
defined in rules so the the rule would
have to be changed but maybe that's
something we should push for um let's
let's have that discussion at one of our
next uh meetings representative Corman
oh appr propo of some of what we've been
hearing maybe we should call it Alchemy
technology
energy then we'd always be first that's
a good idea representative
nter with the American legislators
exchange Council I'm um I chair the
communications and Technology task force
so that would that would put us up but
so all right be thinking of creative uh
ways to rename the committee that get us
closer to the top of the calendar maybe
we could push for that
okay well everybody drive safely on your
way home watch out for the other guy and
uh take it slow and we'll see you uh
care